- Yeah boy, aw yeah.
- Oh, God.
- This is my first coffee of the day.
I need some time to
rev up the engines man.
♪ Tell me what you gonna do now ♪
- Don't talk to me until
I've had my coffee.
(upbeat music)
- You single handedly like,
exhausted our supply.
- All I want is one,
Connor, all I want is one.
I'm not the one drinking like
five fucking capsules a day.
- I don't drink-
- I wonder why
we're through a coffee shortage, Connor.
- Its not me, okay?
- I wonder why.
- It's not me.
(all laughing)
We live in a society.
All right, welcome back to
this episode of Trash Taste,
I'm with the boys,
Garnt and Joey.
- What did you say?
(all speaking gibberish)
- You know what guys?
I'm gonna quit.
(all laughing)
Man, I got a new phone, right?
And I saw the comments are like,
"Oh my god, Connor got
the Pixel 6 already."
I've got it day one, all right?
You're a fake fan. I'm kidding.
So my last phone as some of you guys know,
and I've sort of complained about it,
I had the Pixel 4 before, it was dying,
and I got this phone,
everyone was like, "How is it Connor?"
It's good, but it's also really shit.
(man laughing)
- Why?
- There's so many annoying things
that like I don't know why like-
- Okay.
- So...
Okay, you guys know me,
big fan of my Chromecasts.
I think we're all aware
I love my Chromecasts.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah.
- I think its your most used appliance
like your Nespresso right?
- Yeah, exactly, so I
get on my bed, right?
And I'm like, "Oh, the volume's too loud,
let me turn it down.
Okay.
Normally I would just like
press the volume button
on my phone when its
being cached to the TV
and it would go down.
- Yeah?
- It isn't doing it and
I'm like, "That's weird."
Okay, maybe it's just like
this, maybe its a one off.
And then it doesn't happen again.
Doesn't happen again.
Turns out, yeah, it's
like an intended feature
they just removed it,
and then I was like, "Why?"
And then apparently there was
like, "It's a legal issue."
I'm like, "It's a legal issue
for me to turn my volume up and down?
What's going on?
What's going on Google?"
- Is it to stop people at parties
from like turning the
volume too high maybe?
- I don't think...
Why would that be a legal issue?
That's a dick friend issue, you know?
I was like what-
- Has Google been taking
notes off Apple or something?
(Joey laughing)
It's like, "Guys! Guys!
This is an intended issue."
(Joey laughing)
I think I'm still like the only
person left in fucking 2021
that misses the fucking auxiliary hole.
- No, I don't want that shit bro.
- Sometimes you need it.
- Very rarely it's useful.
- Sometimes you fucking need it.
Sometimes.
- Kids today will never know
the joy of the aux cord.
- Garnt is the reason we don't
have progress in humanity.
He holds on to the artifacts of old.
- I'm sorry that sometimes
you go in an old car or something
that doesn't have Bluetooth connectivity.
I'm sorry that not everyone
owns a fucking Tesla
or something, you know?
- That makes its own music.
- Yeah, some people our
age are still fucking broke
and their radios or their
fucking music player
needs an auxiliary cable.
- I miss the day when I could
say, "Yo, pass me the aux."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, honestly.
- I can't say that shit anymore, dude.
I can't be like, "Yo,
pass me the Bluetooth."
- My brother had the same problem,
when his first car,
he had the cassettes only
that would go into it.
- Aw, hell yeah.
- So he had to get a
cassette to aux cable.
(all laughing)
And that was really cool though
just seeing how it worked.
I don't understand the technology.
- That's gonna come back
in a couple years time.
- There's gonna be cassette to Bluetooth.
- It's like a Bluetooth
cassette you pop in.
(all laughing)
And then it works, I don't know.
I thought that was really cool.
- Soon we're gonna have
vinyl to Bluetooth.
- Point is Garnt is halting progress.
- No, no, no, no, no.
I'm not the one halting progress.
(Connor laughing)
This is the corporations selling us,
like they're making an issue
and then they're selling us the solution.
Like have you seen that Apple are now
like adding more ports-
- Yeah, I saw that, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Even though the people
who've removed the ports
are Apple themselves.
So they're just like, "Apple,
let me sell you on this okay?
Let's create an issue ourselves,
and then let's sell the
solution to our customers
and frame it as a solution
that we didn't make in the first place."
Like what, what!?
- Genius.
- That's true.
But I really hope that everything
just goes USB-C as well.
I want everything to be the fucking same,
and thank God Europe is like, "Hey Apple,
fuck you, do USB-C."
- "We don't care if you're
Apple, we're Europe."
- I'd say I like it, you know?
As much as, yeah, proprietary
technology and all that shit.
Wouldn't it be nice if it's like,
"Can I borrow your charger?"
You don't have to ask,
"What charger do you have?"
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- What a society we would live in bro.
What's that meme with
the flying spaceships
and this advanced civilization.
- This is civilization.
- This is where we would have been
if everyone agreed on
USB-C like years ago,
that's literally like...
- Well, it's just basically
everyone and then Apple,
which is just how things are. (chuckling)
- But also USB definitely
suffered from all that shit
a while back as well
with micro B and micro-
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then USB-C came along
and everyone was like,
"This is shit."
And then everyone was like "Well, hold up,
it's actually not that bad.
It's good. We like this."
- Yeah, you can plug it in either way
and it just works,
and people were just like,
"What, you can do that?"
- It solved an issue.
- But yeah, no, I think
buying this phone was good.
I like the camera.
That's all that's good about it,
but everything else is kind
of, I'm not a big fan of.
- Yeah, going back on
the like auxiliary thing
and just proprietary things that I miss,
is just a lot of the times
I don't really see a point
in buying a new phone.
I normally just buy a new
phone most of the time
because the battery life
just gets shit, right?
But I was completely
fine with my old phone.
If the battery life
hadn't reduced over time,
I would have still kept my old phone,
because what new features are
you using your new phone for
that you're not using your old phone for?
- I will say one thing, and
this is just a YouTuber thing.
Being able to have a somewhat
good camera in your pocket
if I need some B-roll or something
or I need like a little
vlog bit is super useful.
- That's the only reason why
updated to the new iPhone,
because the camera on that,
I don't have to lug around
a huge DSLR all the time.
- And also I'm a big tech nerd, right,
so I want to get the new stuff.
So the fact that it lines up
as like a justifiable
reason in my mind for work,
it's like a no brainer for
me, like I'm gonna do it.
Now, this is the first
year in like five years
where I didn't upgrade
my phone after one year.
- Yeah.
- I have waited-
- Really?
- Normally I did it every year.
I don't know why.
I just found that I must
have been buying shit phones
that kept getting...
To be fair, I used my phone a lot
like more than the average person I'd say.
I'm playing videos on it nonstop.
And yeah, this time I waited two years
and I really felt it in the last year,
because like my God was
my phone being shit.
- Yeah, but was being shit about it?
- Battery was the main issue obviously.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
that's always the main issue
but I was definitely getting
like the CPU slowdown issue
where like stuff was getting slow.
Sometimes I would press
the lock screen button
and more often than not
it just wouldn't open,
and then sometimes it would open
but then I had been pressing it so much
that now it was buffering
all of the opening
and then I was trying to do it
and it would like just start spazzing out.
So a lot of issues.
- [Man] Doesn't happen to an iPhone.
- Yeah, it does happen to an iPhone.
Are you kidding me?
- It definitely does happen to an iPhone.
- Fuck right off, I've had iPhones.
- I literally had an iPhone
and then I switched to Samsung
because I was like encountering
too many different issues with it.
- The reason why I changed to Android
is 'cause my iPhone was just
being so fucking temperamental.
Like it was breaking
so much after one year.
- Really, that was the opposite for me,
my Samsung phone was being so shit
that I changed back to an iPhone.
- I guess it depends like on
which phone you get, right?
I think the last one I got
was like the 6, iPhone 6.
- Yeah.
- That was quite awhile ago.
- Yeah, yeah.
But then that's because
I done iPhone 4, 5 and 6,
and I was getting more and more annoyed
with each generation.
I was like, "Fuck this."
- Yeah.
- Ah, fair enough.
- And I just like the customizability
that you have with these
Android phones as well.
- It's really easy to like download apps
that you aren't supposed to on Android,
(Garnt laughing)
that aren't on the app store.
On Apple it's like-
- Android, built for the bad boys.
- On Apple it's like, "Hey,
do you wanna just like
do a criminal offense in some countries
and void your warranty
in every other country
by jailbreaking it?"
It kinda sucks.
And sometimes, I didn't
want to jailbreak it.
I just wanted one thing
that I had to jailbreak it for
and I was like, "Okay, well shit."
I just didn't jailbreak it in the end
'cause I was like, "I'm a good boy,
fine, I'll be a good boy, fine."
- [Joey] I'll be a good Christian boy.
- 'Cause Android it's just like,
"Just download the APK
and then install it."
- Yeah, is that phone
bigger than your last phone,
'cause I noticed that
it was like a chonky boi
when I held it.
- Yes.
- The chonk chart.
- I like the visor though.
I like this, it's like Daft Punk.
(all laughing)
Is it not?
It's got like mad Daft Punk vibes.
I like that.
- See, I was going-
- It looks kind of like like "Among Us."
(all laughing)
- No, it doesn't look
like fucking Among...
Get the fuck outta of here!
This does not look like "Among Us."
- I can't be the only one
that thought that, right?
I can't be the only one that thought that.
- This doesn't look like "Among Us."
- You will never not see it now.
- Now I can't unsee it.
You know, you should
get a red case for that.
- Yeah, get a red case.
- Get a red case.
- But keep the visor, keep the visor over.
- Who makes skins? dbrand?
Is that who it is?
- Yeah.
- dbrand, give me an "Among Us" skin.
- Yeah, a red skin.
- Get the "Among Us" skin.
Overall, right, you know,
I've been waiting for the Pixel 6
for like, I'd watch every..
- Why?
- Because like I got sucked up into that,
I'd watch the Marques Brownlee's,
I'd watch the whoever else there was.
Everyone who isn't Marques Brownlee
'cause no one else has like, you know?
- Marques Brownlee and-
- That's how it is with tech YouTubers.
Its like Marques
Brownlee, Linus Tech Tips,
everybody else, to the normies, right?
I know there's other
people, I'm just joking.
But like...
- Austin Evans crying right now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
But that's the thing, right?
My mum can watch Marques Brownlee.
My mum likes Marques
Brownlee's videos, right?
And I don't know what it is-
- Why?
- Because somehow he makes
tech very approachable
to like absolutely anybody.
Like when I watched Linus Tech Tips,
it's good but it's definitely for someone
who like likes their tech.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Like you have to have knowledge,
and like there were some other
ones as well who had decent,
but I think Marques
Brownlee somehow just gets
the perfect balance of like
appealing to like enthusiasts,
but also appealing to like my mom.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, I don't know.
So that's probably why
he's just so successful though as well.
- Yeah, I mean, like when I was
like gonna upgrade my phone,
I was like, "Should I
move away from Samsung?"
And I like started watching
a load of tech videos,
like comparison videos,
which is the best phone to get in 2021.
And then I watched like several
fucking 20 minute long videos
comparing like the Samsung to the iPhone
or the Pixel and you know, the
OnePlus and then I realized
I have no idea what any of
these guys are talking about.
And like, the difference
that I'm gonna find
is gonna be minuscule with every-
- I've just found out that
with most of those videos,
at the end of it all,
they'll give you all
these like tech rundowns
of like, "Yeah, it's
better than the iPhone
but better on the Samsung,"
but then at the end you'll just be like,
"Yeah, so which one's better?
It really depends on what you want
to use the phone for really.
It's up to you I guess.
Whatever you prefer."
- "The Samsung is like .5% better
at taking pictures at night time
so if you're gonna take
pictures at night,"
and I'm just like-
- If you're a night photographer only.
- And here in my mind,
I'm just like, "Well, I've
never taken pictures at night
but maybe I'm gonna start
in the next year, you know?
This might be something I need
to like pay attention to."
And then after like overloading
myself with information,
I just realized none of this
actually fucking matters.
All that matters is
the fucking price point
and the functioning.
- And your personal choice.
- The camera clearly
doesn't fucking matter
because every single
video of any public event
with a camera ever seems to be in 360p.
So like clearly, the
people who are at these
like fucking Walmart fights,
don't have the newest
iPhone filming in 4K HDR.
'Cause I don't see these fights in 4K.
- That is true.
- People aren't uploading TikTok's
in like fucking 8K resolution,
although our phones can't
shoot 8K resolution.
I don't know when we'd ever use it.
- You know what's weird?
Is that I've had,
so my last phone was the Pixel 4, right?
Before that I had the OnePlus 7 Pro.
Whichever one had the camera
that like manually came out,
like it was a motor but the
camera came out the top.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And to this day that's
still like the best camera
I used for filming on my phone,
like it was better than my Pixel 4
and I think it's still better than this
because it can do 4K.
- [Garnt] Right.
- And you can change all the
settings like in the camera.
Problem was is that I
had to buy a new phone
because when I moved to Japan,
OnePlus doesn't work in Japan
because Japan has its own
type of frequency waves
or something that it uses
that no other country uses.
- We're not like the others.
- Yeah, so if you want
to buy a phone make sure,
I'm pretty sure like none
of the Chinese phones
work in Japan.
- No, that's not true.
- Really?
- I used a Huawei phone.
- Huawei works.
- Huawei's fine.
- Huawei works?
- Yeah, Huawei works.
- Oh okay well OnePlus doesn't
work and a few other ones.
- Just fuck OnePlus in particular.
- I think OPPO phones,
I don't see them ever here.
- They do sell them here.
- Really?
- I've seen OPPO phones being sold.
- I wonder was it just fuck OnePlus then?
- It's literally just fuck OnePlus.
- Okay.
- To be fair, I hadn't heard of OnePlus
until you bought one and
you started raving about it.
I'd never heard of fucking OnePlus.
- Well, to be fair I had it,
way back, it was really good.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then recently their
phones have been kinda-
- You are the only person I've ever known
that's owned a OnePlus.
- Okay.
If somebody owns a OnePlus,
then normally like they
follow like tech stuff
'cause it's definitely
like a tech person phone
or at least it was.
It was like really good specs
and stuff for a good price.
- For a good price, right?
- And then now they just do
what everyone else is doing,
which is like good specs for high prices
so it doesn't fucking matter.
- Fair enough.
- Yeah. I mean, that's just like that's...
I don't pay too much
attention to the tech world
I pay attention when I
need to buy something new.
- Yeah, here's the problem with it.
Yeah, that's the problem
with phones, right?
Like as much as I think like
the Galaxy Fold looks sick,
it's like I didn't want to
buy a phone at that time.
And then by the time
I want to get a phone,
I probably want to get one that's newer
so that I'm not getting one that's-
- Well, is the Galaxy Fold even worth it?
- I don't know, it just
looks sick doesn't it?
- It looks really cool.
- Imagine folding your phone.
- What's the unique selling
point apart from just
it folds.
- It folds!
That's it! That's all you need!
- Bro, imagine the power
move where you text someone
and you fucking slam your
phone right afterwards.
You're like, "Fuck this person."
You're like fucking...
- [Man] There's the same
thing with the Motorola.
They came up with the
new smartphone as well
where it can just like...
It's basically a flip phone but it's...
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So it's a fashion piece.
- Well, yeah but like,
so is everything in your fucking life.
- Well, that's why Apple
makes so much money, right?
- Yeah, even though I like,
there's some things that
Apple make that I don't like.
Like I-
- Have you seen,
have you seen the conference
video of when Apple
announced the price of their monitor arm?
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah.
(all laughing)
- That was so good.
- That was pretty ridiculous.
- That felt like that should
have been like the website,
kind of like just let it
pop up on the website.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know when you're
making a presentation
and you know if the audience
isn't gonna be happy
and it's just like, "Oh
and so the monitor arm
is gonna be priced at $999.
And moving on."
And it's like you can just
tell how nervous he was
and how much he had to like
mentally rehearse that in his mind
before he said it out loud.
- It's like me listing my Christmas list
to my mum when I was a child.
It's a $200. Anyway, the other one is $10.
It is a pack of Uno cards after all.
One thing that I've
never understood, right?
I got smart watch, right?"
- Yeah.
- I hate, I think that Apple
watches look like toys.
I don't understand why people wear them.
- To be fair, I think they
look kind of ugly as well.
- They look like a toy.
They look like something
that like Ben 10 would wear.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Except less cool.
- It looks like something
I'd raise like Pokemon on,
you know? (laughing)
- And everyone wears them.
- Yeah.
- But like, I like the smart watches-
- I don't like square watches.
- I like the smart watches
that look like watches
because then you don't look like
you're about to go to Silicon Valley
and sell stock, you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- I don't know.
Do you guys look at the Apple watches
or are you indifferent?
- I mean,
I'm very indifferent.
I don't wear watches.
- You don't even wear a watch.
- I don't wear smart watches either.
- I wear smartwatch but just
because I like the buzz,
it just buzzes, I don't look at it.
I just want to know
because I put my phone on silent.
- See, I don't like that
because I get bombarded
with enough notifications on my phone
that sometimes I just need
to like put my phone aside
and be like "Okay, there's a separation."
But to me if I wear a smart watch
then I'm constantly like getting bombarded
with notifications and you know-
- That's why I stopped
wearing a smart watch.
I just wear the Jojo watch
just because again like-
- I want to wear my Jojo watch
but I also don't want to ruin it.
I'm scared to like ruin it's value.
- Yeah, same here.
- I guess but it's like I don't know,
I liked the smart watch at first
'cause I was like, "Oh cool,
I can fucking see everything
without opening my phone,
this is great.
Maybe it'll stop me from
getting on my phone."
It didn't. (laughing)
It just prolonged the process
of me actually pulling out
my phone to check everything.
- I don't know for me
personally it's helped where
I don't always want to,
99% of texts I don't reply to immediately.
And I want to find out do
I need to reply to this
so when I feel a buzz,
I just check, all right, not important.
All right, and I'm not
getting my phone out.
I'm just gonna carry on.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- That's kind of what I do.
- For me, because we do get bombarded
with a lot of notifications,
emails like Twitter whatever,
but I just want to like...
When I'm trying to be productive,
I want to just like get
all this done in one point.
Like I want to reply to all
my messages in one point,
all my notifications in one point,
and then just leave it aside.
But like I feel for me
if I had that constant
buzz on my fucking wrist
I just wouldn't be able to concentrate
'cause I'd be like is this...
- You'd think so, at first yes, you do.
But then after time it's like anything,
you just kind of become numb to it
and sometimes I've been buzzed a bunch
and I don't even realize it.
- Doesn't that completely
defeat the purpose though?
(all laughing)
- I think I need to like
build in a taser or something.
Ah! Jesus Christ.
- You need to replace it
with like a shock dog collar.
- Yeah.
- I think so like...
Yeah, I don't know.
And also honestly I kind
of like how it looks,
I don't know, I like the style.
- That is a nice watch.
- Yeah, right?
It's one of the ones that
looks decent so, yeah.
Something about the it
being square makes it...
'Cause the watch in your mind
is like ingrained as a circular shape.
Watch is circular, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yes.
- So like when I see a square,
I don't know what it is about
my brain that just thinks...
- That's a construct of your mind, bro.
- Right, that is.
Well, just how like a stand
should cost less than $100
is a construct of my mind.
(all laughing)
I think we...
- Bro, just expand your mind,
bro.
- It's not just a PC
case that costs a grand.
It's a cheese grater.
- Bro, just wait. Circular monitors.
(all laughing)
- The future is now.
- Think about it, bro.
(laughing)
- We make our watches square
and our monitors circular.
(laughing)
- I don't know.
- Welcome to the future.
- Is it weird that I care
about the watch being square?
Like am I being pedantic there.
- No, no no.
I mean, that's the exact
reason why I don't have a-
- I think you're being pedantic.
- Fuck you, Garnt. Fuck you.
(laughing)
- That's the exact reason why
I don't have a fucking iWatch either.
Is it called an iWatch?
- Well, (indistinct)
you wear a square watch.
What do you like about the square watch?
- Just square, is nice.
- He likes squares.
- It's like a SpongeBob on your hand?
- [Man] Yeah. It's like...
(imitates SpongeBob)
(all laughing)
- What?
- The fuck was that?
- I don't know. Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know.
- [Man] It's like I really
like my square watch.
- I don't know why I feel
so strongly about it.
I understand I completely have no right.
- I mean, I feel what you're saying
just not as strongly as you.
- I don't know why I I
feel so strongly about it.
- I mean, for me, like
tech has always just been
application and functionality.
Like I've never really
cared too much about
having the newest tech
as long as I get something
that gets me my work done
or gets me the functionality that I need,
and I guess that's just
like my engineering mind,
like I don't care how it works.
I just care that it gets
the fucking job done.
- Yeah.
- He's just min-maxing
his life, you know?
- I think that's why this new
phone's annoyed me so much.
Is that in like from
a specification level,
it's amazing and it's got
some really cool features,
but the one thing that it pisses me off
is that just sometimes little
things are being annoying
on this phone and that's
what pisses me off.
- Do you know the biggest thing
that me off about this phone,
and it's such a minor thing
- What's the phone by the way?
- It's a Samsung S21,
I think.
Yeah. S21.
So where'd you think the power button is?
- On the side?
- Oh, is it below the volume?
- No, so the power button
is you have to press these two buttons
at the same time.
- Oh.
- It used to be, it used to be this button
but what's this button?
It's the Bixby button.
And Bixby is like meant to be like
the Samsung equivalent to like Siri,
but I don't know a single fucking person
who's ever used Bixby in my life.
- I've just heard about
Bixby about five seconds ago.
- You didn't know what Bixby was?
- No.
- What?
- Who the fuck uses Bixby?
- No one, but Samsung
puts it in every device.
- It sounds like a Rugrats character.
(Garnt laughing)
- It is.
- Yeah.
- It's like being someone
who uses Bing, you know?
Like who are these people?
Who are these people?
- Well, I'm still using
Ask Jeeves actually,
I mean, that's a good brand.
- All right, all right.
- I'm still using Clippy.
- Okay this is what, I love Android right?
But this is what they have been
pissing me off with lately.
Every time they add something
they take away something
or change it a lot, right?
So I remember on my old phone,
you used to be able to
screenshot the whole page.
So it would scroll down,
and then for some reason one day
they just removed it, they didn't say why.
Why would you remove that
and then not add anything to replace it?
And now they've added it
back in with the new one,
but for like two years I lost the ability
to screenshot the whole page.
- That's right, the selling point.
- Right, right.
- You're being sold on
the new functionality.
- It's a classic Apple, a classic Apple.
And then I remember when
you wanted to screenshot,
it used to be simple,
I think you just press
the power button down
and then it would like...
Oh, no, no, you could press like a combo
and you could screenshot.
and then they changed it to
like hold the power button down
and then you press it to
screenshot, something like that.
I can't remember exactly.
But they just change shit for
no fucking apparent reason
and then they call it new,
and I'm like fuck off!
It's not new if you just made shit
more complicated for me, fuck off.
- And yet he somehow still
is part of the system.
(laughing)
- You're part of the cycle.
- You are trapped, you are trapped.
- You're trapped in the tech cycle.
- They've sucked you in,
they've made you angry
and you can't get out.
- I just like Android too much, you know?
And I don't really have anything to go,
'cause I think a lot
of the time with Apple,
the reason why people are quite loyal
and I know, you know, I understand this,
is that they buy a lot of Apple products.
- Well, that's why you
put the Pixel, right?
'Cause you're part of the Google-
- Yeah, you're part of
the Googlers out there.
- But that's because like
Android works well with Windows
and stuff like that,
it all kind of works well
with each other, you know?
And emulation is easier on
Android and all that stuff.
- Except isn't it weird
that the Pixel doesn't
work with the Chromecast?
- Now it doesn't but
Chromecast is Google's thing.
- Yeah.
So you'd think the one
phone that would work
with something Google related
would be the Google phone, right?
- Yeah, why did they
remove the functionality?
Because I can control mine.
- I can control it with the iPhone.
- Yeah, so now what I have to
do when I want to control it,
instead of going to volume, I
have to go to Google home app,
scroll down to the-
- Oh my God.
- Scroll down to-
- Are you serious?
(both retching)
- Yeah, I know.
Scroll down to the device.
I have three devices in my home as well.
So then I have to click it
and then I have to go
on the volume slider,
it's fucking stupid.
I don't know why Google did this shit,
it's like they fucking hate me, you know?
They already paying my bills with YouTube.
Like, why you making me suffer, Google?
I'm already trapped in your web.
- So what does the volume button do?
- Just normal, normal volume.
- Nothing.
- So it's your phone volume.
- Yeah, but normally when
you'd Chromecast things,
you'd be able to choose
all of the volumes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like sometimes-
- I can still do that on my Samsung.
- Because sometimes
I'll for whatever reason
if I'm feeling like a psychopath,
I'll play a video through my phone,
cast a video and then
maybe I'll be on call
and I can control all the
three volumes separately.
- Yeah, I do that sometimes.
Welcome to an influencer's life.
We've become that meme
of just like that guy
who has like four screens
looking at like the stock
market or something.
- Four different videos.
- Instead of stocks, it's just memes.
- You need to like
consume all of the memes
at the same time.
- I did something one time and I was like,
what the fuck's wrong with me?
I was just watching two videos
and both volumes were playing
and then I realized 30
seconds into doing it
I was like yeah, I can't
hear, I can't hear it.
- Yeah.
- I was just listening
to both at the same time
and trying to take them both in
and I don't know why.
There's no apparent reason.
- Really challenging yourself or?
- No, I wasn't doing it consciously.
I just did it by accident and
then I just didn't stop it.
I was just letting them
both play and I was like,
this is good.
- I need some more sleep.
- I have an issue of opening too many tabs
and sometimes-
- Yeah, I've seen.
- Sometimes one of the
tabs is playing volume
and it's like fucking
trying to find where's Wally
in the fucking tab section.
It's just like which one of these
is playing fucking music right now?
- How many tabs on
average do you have open?
- Okay, okay, okay.
I'm not a psychopath.
I've seen some people who have like 100
or like you know-
- How can the browser
even run at that point?
- I've seen tabs when it's just like,
it gets like 20 tabs and
then you have to like click
and expand shit to get
like the next 20 tabs.
That's just like a fucking psychopath.
- Yeah, I think when it
gets to like 50 tabs,
it condenses it down into one drop down.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think its like 30.
- Is it?
- Yeah, it's like 30.
- Too many, too many.
- Yeah, so what I do
is if it's like 10 tabs
and I you know, in case
I don't want to close
one of the tabs, I just
open another window
and I stack them on top of each other.
- How much ram is that using?
- I don't know. (laughing)
- How much ram do you have in your PC?
- I feel like...
- Not enough.
- It's funny because when I'm editing,
when I'm editing even like
heavy intensive videos, right?
I look at the ram usage and
Google Chrome is like still more
than my editing software
a lot of the time.
- Close your fucking browsers, Garnt.
- What if I need it?
What if I need it? Just in case.
- You don't need it.
- There's a thing
called history that
saves it all, you know?
- Obviously you do not know how many memes
I have to go through.
- Maybe you should just view your memes
in like incognito or something
that is not important.
- Because like what if
I have to have like,
if I have like one
important research topic
that I need to use for
like a video or something-
- Research topic, you're
just watching fucking memes.
- No, I have the one tab
that is the important research topic
that I'm working on for a video
and then I have like 30 meme tabs,
and finding that one research
tab is fucking impossible.
(laughing)
- What if you just separate the research
into a different window?
- Because with the length that memes last,
I'm always constantly
looking up new memes.
- I feel like you have some
kind of issues here, Garnt,
just putting them into
categories and actually,
I don't know, organizing
your fucking tabs, Garnt.
- Probably, probably.
Probably that would help me.
- Yeah, that would help.
- I literally try to have as
little tabs open as possible
because I just don't want tabs open.
- If I have more than five,
I start closing ones that I don't need.
- Yeah, yeah.
Five is like the limit.
- Five is a limit.
- Oh, five is like, five is basic.
(laughing)
- Level one.
- I'll have Twitter open, emails, YouTube
and that's it really.
- If I have to have more
than five tabs open,
I'm opening another window.
- Yeah on the another
monitor or something.
- And just put it on another monitor.
- So you got a tab for
YouTube, Twitter, emails,
something for music maybe
or like a video to play in the background.
- No, I just sing.
(laughing)
I am the juke box,
that's what they called me in high school.
- Whatever you're searching at the time-
- I don't constantly have like
Twitter open or my emails.
- Oh, I do.
- I don't.
- How are you going to
go to the fresh memes?
(laughing)
How are you gonna see what
hentai you've watched?
(laughing)
- I have my phone open constantly,
just scrolling with the other hand.
- I do the fucking awful thing
where I have Twitter open like I scroll,
I scroll up on my Twitter, I
see the completed timeline,
close that, open my phone and
open up Twitter. (laughing)
Oh my God fucking dammit, Garnt.
- Oh my God, yeah, I do that.
- Social media has
hacked your fucking mind.
- I'll open the BBC's or
read the news articles.
I'll close it and then 10 minutes later,
I'll open it again to
see if anything happened.
- All right, so here's the thing.
You wake up, you open your phone.
What's the first thing you check?
What's the first app you open up?
- It's whatever the
notifications are really.
- Yeah, I look at the notifications.
- I kind of like look at
is there any of these which
are like super important?
Any of these-
- Are there ever any
super important though?
- Sometimes.
Sometimes you wake up
and like shit's gone wrong or something.
- My LINE messages really are
the first ones where I'm like,
oh yes, this requires immediate attention.
Everything else is like whatever.
- If it's email, then it's
not gonna be important.
- No.
- Because if someone-
- If I see a video,
if I wake up and I see
an email from YouTube,
I'm like-
- Okay, no, that-
- Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's when my heart sinks.
No YouTuber ever wants to
see an email from YouTube.
- It's literally like you never
want to hear from your boss.
If you get a YouTube, it's sucks right?
Because sometimes you
YouTube will email you
and be like, "Here's the
community roundup of stuff."
It's like, fuck off YouTube you scared me!
Because normally it means a
copyright claim or something.
So YouTubers are scared to death
of seeing anything related to YouTube
in their fucking inbox.
- Yeah.
It's like a copyright claim or worse.
Like your channel has
been terminated or your-
- Your video has been age restricted.
- Yeah, your video has
been age restricted.
Nothing good ever comes
out of a YouTube email.
I could get a YouTube email being like,
"We've decided to send you $1 million
for being such a good YouTuber,"
and I'd still get a fucking
heart attack or something.
- True, true.
Ah.
Hmm.
Probably.
I think I go through my
notifications first obviously.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So I'll check it,
you know, LINE.
I mean, you know,
do you have multiple messaging apps
like that people can contact you on?
- Yes.
- And do you have a personal
like number one priority
app, that one that like,
this is the one where if
you messaged me on here
I will actually see it and reply.
- Yeah, to me it's like LINE
and Facebook Messenger, yeah.
- [Connor] Facebook Messenger is like-
- That's a fucking lie, you
don't respond to your LINE.
- Well that's like-
- Garnt doesn't respond to messages.
- Garnt does not respond to messages,
its actually impossible.
- I respond to messages
when I check my messages
and I do not check my messages
when I get notifications.
That's just what I have to do.
- You are like my friend from,
we had a friend from school, right?
And he was always kinda a little odd
but he was a good friend,
we used to play Xbox a lot,
but he was just always so stoic
and very strange with like communication.
Like we would always play Xbox right?
But then when summer
holidays would come around,
he'd be like, "All right, guys,
I'm just not gonna talk
to you all summer."
And we were like, "All right,"
but he wouldn't.
He would just disappear all summer
and it was like okay, strange.
And then whenever you messaged him,
you'd see him at school you're like,
"Yo, why don't you reply to my messages?"
He's like, "I didn't want to."
And, we'd be like what? (laughing)
- What an asshole.
- Yeah.
And then at prom, right?
We were at prom and we're like,
we're just having a good
time and then we're like,
"Yeah dude, we should grab some drinks."
And then at prom he was like,
"I'm never gonna see any
of you guys ever again."
And we were like, what?
- Wow.
- And then to this day,
we never saw him again.
(all laughing)
I gotta say, he's a man of his word.
- Wow.
- At least you can't say he was wrong.
- Bro, you know what was weird,
like two or three years later
he messaged us on Facebook
and we played during the,
it might've been, when
was "Fortnite" popular?
When was Ninja like the biggest-
- Two or three years ago?
- Yeah, whenever that happened,
we played like a few games
of "Fortnite" one day
and then haven't heard from him again.
(Joey laughing)
So that was interesting.
- Last online, nine years ago.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Well, actually I know what he's up to
'cause my friend is,
my friend's dad is best
friends with his dad so, yeah.
So, he's alive.
- [Joey] Yeah, he's alive.
- He's doing well. He's doing well.
- He just doesn't want
to see you. (laughing)
- You know, I get it.
Some people want to move on after school.
I get it but I don't know,
to me it was like damn, this man was sure.
- Its not like he was getting
like bullied or anything?
- No, no, no. We were his friends.
(Joey laughing)
We were literally his friends.
- Well, clearly not.
- We hung out with him more than anyone,
and this guy has decided
that he was just done. (laughing)
- He's like friendship over, you know?
- This man like just did
the IRL friendship remove
in front of us and like we
thought he was like joking.
- Friendship with Connor ended.
"Fortnite" is my friend now.
- Yeah, I met up with some of my friends
when I was back in the UK,
there was the two friends.
So we had a friend group of the four of us
and it was the three of us and not him.
We met up and we were just like,
"Yeah, that was weird. Huh?
How he just, he really was a
man of his word to the end.
Really just disappeared."
- He literally just went through
his Facebook friend list
IRL and was just like,
"Guys, I'm gonna start
clearing off my friend list.
You know? If I unfriend
you don't worry about it."
- Well, that's weird, right?
'Cause he didn't delete
any of us on Facebook
and I think if I messaged
him, he would reply
but he just was like,
"I'm never gonna ever make an effort
to talk to you ever again."
It was true.
- The man knows what he wants, right?
- In some ways I respect the conviction.
I wish I had that amount
of conviction at age 18
to decide to make a life choice like that
to just cut people out.
- This episode is sponsored by Apari,
an artist owned apparel brand
featuring original content,
except this time they've collaborated
with Crypton Future Media
to bring an officially licensed
drop with Hatsune Miku.
- Ooh!
- Ooh, Joey,
what is that I see?
Is that Drip?
No, Joe, I don't think you're dripping.
You're leaking right now.
- [Connor] Well, I'm glad that
you think it's drip, Garnt,
because this is a two part collection
and this is only part one!
- No!
- Number two is coming soon
so if you don't wanna miss out,
follow Apari's Instagram
which is @apariart
and mailing list at apari.com
Joey also modeled for the part one pieces,
which is this collection
and I'm wearing it.
This is the Hatsune Miku hoodie.
- Hell yeah. The back is nice.
- You can see the back right here
and oh, this fabric feels good, man.
- Did you know the Miku
shirts are 100% cotton
and they're pigment dyed or tie dyed?
- I can actually feel it.
- Oo ooh.
- And the Miku Haroi is 100% linen.
And the button downs,
breathable and lightweight
they're made of eucalyptus
and bamboo blend.
- Eucalyptus? That's from Australia.
- And the hoodies,
heavyweight and 100% cotton.
- So if you want to
get any of these items,
please check the link in the description
- Thank you again Apari for
sponsoring this episode.
Now back to the show. Bye!
- Yeah I mean,
how many of the people
you still like met at 18
or friends with in high school,
do you still keep in contact with?
- High school?
Ah, like actually a fair amount,
occasionally just because
it was very small.
- Yeah, I still have like a Facebook group
of like all my friends from high school.
- It was a really small town
so it's a lot easier to, you know,
you knew everyone.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And you know, your
parents know everyone.
So it's really hard not to
like have some form of like,
oh, this so-and-so is up to this stuff.
- Yeah, that's weird for me,
because I remember whenever
I go visit Sidney's hometown
and Sidney's family,
we'd just be like go
shopping to a supermarket
or like going in town and she'd be like,
"Oh yeah, she taught me
history in high school,
oh yeah, she's friends with the fucking-
- Just small town things.
- Am I right fellow Wisconsinites?
- And I'm just like I can't imagine
ever like running into
my teacher in normal life
because if that happens like in my city,
it's like DECFCON five, you know,
like something bad's gone wrong.
- See, my teachers emailed me.
- Really?
- Yeah.
'Cause they told me to, did I say I went
and gave a presentation at school?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I did, right? Yeah.
'Cause my old teacher
guy reached out to me
and he was like, "Hey, Connor."
- Old teacher guy.
- Actually no, the students reached out
but then he liked me so
he was like, "Hey Connor,
yeah, come on over, come on in."
So I can just like walk in...
So here's the thing, right?
Is that I was speaking
to an American and they,
okay, this is gonna sound like another
Connor's American story.
- Yeah.
- We were sitting there
and so they were from Florida,
and we were talking about this
and they were like, "Wait
so there's like no
security at your school?"
I was like "No, there's
no security at my school."
They were like, "What if
like something bad happens?"
I'm like, "Bad things
don't happen at school."
- Yeah.
- This is school.
What do you mean?
Like the teachers can handle it.
What do you mean? It's kids.
It's fine.
Like what if someone comes in with a gun?
No one has guns.
No 12 year olds have guns. (laughing)
"There's no metal detectors?"
No, no, that's crazy.
- That's so alien to me.
- You think we can afford metal detectors?
We can barely afford chairs.
We're like we've been
using the same chairs
for like the past 80 years in my school,
we don't have chairs.
- Like if you're in a school
and you had to open up the textbook
and you didn't have to
share your fucking textbook,
you knew you're in a good fucking school.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So like I could like,
you know, I could, if I was going in
you know, if I just said
one of the teachers is like
is asking me to come in,
even if they don't know anything,
I can just walk in and be like,
"Hey, the school told me I was coming"
and they're like "Oh okay, cool."
'Cause they like, know who I am.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I was an ex student.
- Yeah and even if its like a good school,
it's like the most you have to do
is maybe like, you know,
go to the reception
and say like "Hey, I'm
here for da, da, da."
And then you can just go in, right?
You don't have to go through
this whole like prison system.
- Yeah, yeah, I was like what do you mean?
- You don't have to go through the TSA
every time you go to school.
- Yeah and then when I was done,
I just went around to speak
to the teachers that I liked
and I was like, "Hi, how you doing?
Are you doing well? Nice.
Yeah. Nice, cool, cool.
How's life?
Yeah, still teaching.
Cool, great. Nice."
(laughing)
- Imagine going to a school
that's actually safe.
- Yeah, right.
Oh my God.
Worst thing that happened was
fucking me climbing a tree
and then nearly just jumping out of it,
and that's the worst thing that happened.
- Thought it was it like you
getting into fights or something.
- That too, yeah, yeah.
- Did you have to go
to detention for that?
What punishment system did
you have in your school?
- Nothing physical I
assume in this day and age.
- No.
- Yeah.
- I think some of the tutors
would have loved to though.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Some of the older ones
I could tell they were
more than happy to try it.
- Like undoing the belt.
(Connor laughing)
Now? Now? Aw.
- Yeah, did you guys have
detention in your school?
- Yeah, of course.
- We had a thing,
I forgot what it was called in Welsh.
- What is it?
- You sit in a room facing a wall,
it's like a tiny, tiny room
and you just face a wall.
- Yeah.
We had the same thing
where our teachers would
just tell the students
to just look at the fucking corner.
(laughing)
Like go stand on the wall, right?
And that's how it was until
I entered high school, right?
Because to me the word detention,
that was an American thing,
that was an American punishment.
Our school was in Britain,
we just looked at the wall.
We looked at a wall.
- We called it Blair witching.
(all laughing)
- You know, whenever I got into a fight,
I think I only went there once
and that was from one of the fights
but most of the time I
went like full lawyer mode
when I was a kid I was like,
"Hell no, your honor!
He hit me first! There is
no way I'm doing this!"
- Self defense!
- Yeah, yeah. (laughing)
And then I think one time they were like,
"You need to go to detention."
I'm like, "I'm not going to detention."
They're like, "What do you mean why?"
I'm like, "Because he hit me fucking...
I'm not going in detention."
And then they were like, "Hm."
(all laughing)
I would've gone to detention
if they actually made me do it
but I was like trying to fight back.
And one time they did make me go.
- See, I didn't have the
balls to like retaliate.
- I think after I'd got in fight,
like adrenaline was like high,
I think I was willing to fight back
'cause most of the time
I'd be like okay so.
- I think the reason why
I could never retaliate
to my teachers is because
like in my head I was like,
if I did that to my dad for instance,
he'd beat my ass.
So like, what's to say that the teacher's
not gonna beat my ass as well?
I was conditioned from a young age.
- Same though, like if
I know if my teachers
called up my parents, which
they did multiple times,
I would get fucking annihilated.
- It's like, "Oh I'm dead, I'm dead."
- They would kill me. They
would actually kill me.
They would like take away
my Xbox for like two weeks
and I'd rather frankly-
- Sure death.
- They honestly could like,
could leave me out to dry with no food.
Easy, right? I'll do that.
Take my Xbox away for two weeks?
All right. Real shit.
All right, now, okay,
now I'm gonna do anything
possible to avoid-
- They never told me that there
was a fate worse than death.
(all laughing)
- Legitimately, they could take away,
they could like starve me for three days
and I'd be like, "As long
as I have my 'Halo 3' copy
and 'Halo: Reach', I'll be fine."
Like legitimately,
I'm pretty sure I would
have preferred that.
So I avoided it but I know the one thing,
the one thing that my parents
would like have my back on
is if someone started a fight
with me and I fought back
so I was always very confident.
I was like, "Yeah, what you gonna do?
Tell my parents? Yeah, they'll
tell me, 'Good on you.'"
(all laughing)
They'll be like, "My son's good."
My dad will be like,
"Did he win?" (laughing)
- Comes out with a towel, wipe you down.
Ready for round two?
All right, you guys ready?
- They'll pour some water on me,
they're like, "Get back in
there, son, go back in."
- Hit him with a jab, hit him with a jab!
(all laughing)
Its genuinely one of the only things
where I felt like I could
get away with doing it
because my parents legitimately
would have my back.
But that's why I didn't mind fighting back
'cause I knew that, you know,
if I genuinely felt like
I was in a position to
fight back, I would.
It worked, but I wouldn't
recommend it for everyone.
(Garnt laughing)
If you fight back and
you lose, it's worse.
- That's a different thing, right?
- It's very bad.
Its almost terrible.
You're gonna be bullied everyone so.
To the kids watching
this, know your limits.
- High risk, high reward, right?
- Not even high reward,
its just high risk.
- Yeah, it's just high
risk. It's just high risk.
Yeah. We spoke about that a bunch so.
- Yeah. All right, I need a piss.
- Connor, the psychopath.
- I gotta make piss.
- You know, how were we talking
about like a few weeks ago
how like in like 10 years
we're gonna be laughing out
fucking bass boosted braille
or like Morse code memes or something?
So like, I think I've
already reached that point
because I was watching
a meme the other day
and the meme is just like
called gamers in 2030
and it was just... (laughing)
- It's already funny.
- And I was just pissing myself.
It was just that scene
from "WALL-E", right?
With like the kids on like
the tricycles or whatever.
And it was just them looking
at sorting algorithms.
And I don't know why it was so funny.
It was just them sorting
algorithm and fart noises.
(all laughing)
- I feel like I have to see this.
- My sense of humor is so fucking-
- This is most certainly
one of those memes
that is fucking awful to explain.
- Yeah.
- I can't explain why I think it's funny.
- It's probably the farting noises.
- I think I was just like,
I was more laughing at the
fact that I found this funny.
It was just like a fucking laugh loop.
It just kept going.
- You're laughing
at yourself laughing.
- I literally can't explain the science
of why found this funny
'cause it makes absolute zero sense.
- Yeah, at all.
- Speaking of memes,
you know what I recently invested in?
- What?
- Let me show you boys.
- Oh yeah, I saw that.
- Oh yeah, yeah. I saw that, saw that.
- I got the Goku Drip jacket.
- How much was that?
- You don't want to know.
- Yeah.
- Really?
- So I think-
- Is it official?
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
so I think it's estimated value is like,
estimated value, the same way
that like NFTs are worth value.
It's like, I think two and a half grand.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- I managed to find it on Yahoo Auction
or some shit for like a grand
where it was like "ripped and torn."
And they showed a picture of it
and it's Japanese standard
of ripped and torn.
On the sleeve, it's like a
tiny bit ripped and stained
and so obviously they'd
like gutted the price
because of that and I was
like "Bro, I'll take that,
its for a meme, I don't need it."
Not gonna lie, the jacket's kind of sick.
(all laughing)
I bought it specifically
for a meme in a video
that will come out at some point,
but I was like I'm gonna wear this maybe/
I'm probably not gonna wear it much,
probably just get it for the meme-
- You need to wear it out.
- But then I am like
okay, I kind of like this.
Then I wore it and I'm like, okay,
yeah, this is kind of sick.
It's kind of sick.
- Yo, this actual drip now.
- I actually understand why it's-
- He finally has the drip.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like I put it on and I was like,
"Oh shit, this is fucking sick."
- Finally, something
to rival the Jojo suit.
- Yeah, Connor discovers
drip for the first time.
- So now when somebody
says I don't have Drip,
I just threw money at the problem.
Money made it go. Don't
even think about fashion.
I literally bought the definition of drip.
I bought the Goku jacket.
I was gonna get the Supreme shirt as well,
but I was like "fuck that."
I just bought a knockoff.
It's like a thousand dollars.
I'm not buying that for a fucking shirt.
The coat, at least it's a North Face coat.
So at least it's a decent coat,
but I mean still it's way over priced
for what it is though, Jesus.
- It is North Face though.
- It felt very high quality though,
but not $1,000 high quality.
- Are you gonna wear that when you go
to like snowboarding
or something like that?
- Well, yeah.
Ah, dude, imagine snowboarding.
- Yeah, that's what I'm thinking.
That's what I'm thinking, man.
- Oh dude!
That would be so...
Dude, I'd be so scared to like rip it
or fall on it though.
'Cause like, dude, what if
I ripped that jacket though?
That's the most expensive
fucking piece of clothing
I've ever bought in my life.
- Yeah.|
- That's insane.
- Well like what was I gonna say?
Like going back to your
Yahoo Auction thing,
I've just noticed that
whenever like a Japanese
person goes to like,
they say on their secondhand store
that it is like bad quality
or it is like a little
ripped, a little something.
It's not at all.
Its basically new 'cause
I had a similar experience
because I just recently
bought a Gilgamesh watch.
So you know how we have
like the Jojo watches?
So they recently, before
that they did a collaboration
with you know, Fate and Faye characters.
So I bought the Gilgamesh one,
and it was like really, really discounted
because on the website it said
"scratches and dents" right?
And I'm just like okay, whatever.
I just want it 'cause it's a Gilgamesh.
So I get it and the scratches and dents
which was like one little
dent on the corner of the box
and one scratch on the
fucking box itself, right?
That's what put its price down.
It's not even on the watch itself.
It was on like the packaging
which I'm not even gonna
show off anyway, right?
- Yeah.
- Japanese secondhand
is not secondhand.
It's like 1.5 hand.
- Yeah, it's weird 'cause some websites,
there's other websites like Mercari
that have ratings and
like, it'll be like AAA
which literally means
that it is probably better than
the fucking factory quality.
- Yeah, like mint condition.
- It's literally like insane.
A is like very good, like a store quality.
And then just like normal A is like good,
like I've bought, so I think the jacket
was listed like AB or something.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Or like BA or something.
Something B and it was fine.
It's literally fine, but
it was like "stained"
but I looked at it,
I couldn't even fucking find the stain
that was in the photo so I don't
understand what's happened.
- Yeah. I used Mercari once to
get that CRT TV that I have.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- And like, fuck.
Okay, so I bought that
for like 300 bucks, right,
which I was like okay,
you know, decent, decent.
Turns out later I found out like
normally for good condition
that thing's usually like five grand.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- And the only reason
it was 300 bucks is because
it was owned by a dude
who took perfect care of it.
And I was like, "What, why?
You could have easily extorted me
for a couple of grand at least for this."
But the dude was like, "300 please."
- Japan is one of the only countries
where I think a lot of
stuff you can just like,
just get it secondhand.
Like you don't really need
to worry about it like don't.
Clothes I've noticed online
are like insane condition somehow.
I don't understand how.
I wear an item of clothing once
and I look shit, it looks
like it's been destroyed.
- I wash it once and I'm just like,
"This is a washed clothes.
I can feel it. I can see it."
- I don't understand.
I don't know what I'm doing wrong,
maybe I'm just like a Neanderthal
with my caveman machine,
I suppose.
- Like even when you go
to like Book Off, right,
and you go to like the
second hand clothing sections
and it's like this is
clearly like old clothing
and it's been slashed down
but you look at it and it's
like what's wrong with it?
- Also video game consoles.
- Oh, yeah.
- Right, yeah.
- Dude, it is insane how easy it is
to get like Nintendo 64 games
in box for less than $10.
- Yeah.
- Like you see "Super
Mario 64" in box everywhere
and it's like 500 yen.
It's like $5 for an in box
copy of "Super Mario 64."
- I've got one and I
paid like 700 yen for it.
- It's insane. It's actually insane.
And you can get Nintendo
64's in box for like $20.
- Yeah, I got mine for like 30.
- It's absurd.
- Its actually stupid.
- The only consoles that are expensive
are stuff like the Neo Geo
and some of the Sega stuff-
- Sega Saturn
is usually quite expensive.
- Some of the Sega ones,
but like any NESes SNESes,
there's so many of them in box
and so many of them outside of the box.
So you can just get like a plastic bag
with a perfect condition N64
or NES or SNES for like $10.
It's insane.
And you can get like the fucking
limited edition GameCubes for cheap.
I know that like the orange one-
- I got the orange one, yeah.
- That's like 60 bucks, 80 bucks.
- Recently like Japan is
just a collector's dream
because there is so many like rare items
that you can find here
for like mint condition.
Like it's actually insane
how good they take care of their stuff.
Like I opened something out of the box,
somehow I get a scratch on it immediately.
I don't know.
- Yeah, exactly right.
- Like my hands touch it
and it just like, I leave
some kind of mark on it.
I don't know how it's possible.
So I don't know how these guys
are taking care of these
mint condition everything.
Every item is mint condition.
- People are just so
careful with stuff here.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- I'm not saying I'm reckless with my,
I'm not fucking throwing them everywhere-
- No.
- But I think they go
to an extreme level of care
to make sure everything is perfect
and it's kept properly.
- Yeah, 'cause like even the books, right?
Even the books, you buy
a book of something.
Normally when I read a book,
you get like the natural
bends with it, right?
Somehow the books are
just perfectly straight,
like mint condition a lot of the times.
I'm just like, how are you doing this?
Are you like reading it with a tweezer?
Are you like...
(all laughing)
Is this like a CSI
crime scene or something
where they're just like-
- Puts on the gloves.
- They open it for a second,
take a picture on the phone
and they read it on the phone.
- Yeah, (laughing)
- I can't crease it, I can't
expose the paper to oxygen,
God forbid.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah. It's actually insane.
So I don't know like
how they got this kind
of culture around them
but that's good for us
'cause we can find so many things here.
You can find so many rare items here.
- Get a cheaper drip jacket
for a ridiculous price.
- I think it's because
in Japan, especially,
it's that whole idea of
like, not so much recycling
but I guess like the whole idea of
oh, if I move or something happens
or if I run out of money,
then like I'm gonna have
to like resell this shit.
So I think a lot of people
just buy it naturally
with the intent to resell it.
- Yeah because like I
feel like resell culture
at least outside it's just to me,
it was like never worth
the time investment
to try and resell something,
unless I knew I owned
something that was like super,
super valuable, like most everyday stuff,
I'm just like, I don't need this.
- Yeah, most of the time
you just throw it out.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
It's more effort to sell for example,
maybe your used clothes.
- I think it's because it's
such a fucking pain in the ass
to throw anything out here in Japan.
- Yeah.
- Like into like trash.
- And also you have to pay
for anything even remotely big.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- Anything bigger than
like 40 centimeters.
- Yeah, so it's like,
why would I pay to get rid of this thing
when I could just resell it
and make money to get rid of it?
- Yeah and also when you
want to throw something away
in Japan, you have to book
when you want to throw it away.
- Yeah.
- And it takes like a month.
- Yeah, so when I was in my
old place I bought the toilet,
but in the new place there
was already one installed.
So I didn't need the bidet, sorry.
So I had to throw it away
and I had to wait two
months to throw it away.
So it was just in my apartment
just collecting dust for two months
before I could throw it away.
Isn't this insane? Two months.
- I had that with my desk as well
and everything like tables and everything.
It's like oh, cool.
40 days from now I can
throw out this piece of shit
I don't need any more.
- Oh, in UK you can just
stick it on Gumtree for free
and someone would come around and take it.
- Hmm, I mean, there are sites
like that in Japan as well.
There just not like
really readily available,
or mostly known about.
- Yeah and also probably not
the best for like foreigners
if you can't read Japanese.
- Yeah, I guess.
- You could probably make it work
with like Google Translate but you know.
- You probably do it on like Mercari
and stuff like that, right?
That's probably why it's so popular.
- Yeah, true, true.
- Yeah, I've realized now that
a lot of websites can be figured out
once you just you have
Google Translate or whatever
and like most of them
work exactly the same way
as most websites work so,
you know it's a big deterrent
because once the rest of
the world figure it out
I'm sure people can be
buying like way cooler shit,
but now it's like we have
all the access to it.
- Yeah, might as well use it.
- Well yeah, I mean a lot of the sites
are popping up with proxy shipping
so we've ordered some of the podcasts,
so yeah, I mean, a lot of the time
you are getting a fucking steal.
- Yeah, I think the hardest one actually
is just Yahoo Action.
Yahoo Auction-
- Dude, I know the language
and I still don't know.
- I've got it set up so I can use it now
but like I have to memorize
some kind of weird like Simon Says,
which panel to click on for which thing.
- Yeah, because it's not like Amazon
where you're just like, "Oh, buy."
It's like, you have to like bid,
it's not bidding is it?
- You bid, you bid, but
there is also buy now.
So it's like eBay, it's literally eBay
but there's an etiquette and
this is where I fucked up
'cause now my account is poorly reviewed
because I didn't reply saying
I got the item to the seller.
I assumed that he got the confirmation
that the package had been sent.
And so he wrote like a really angry,
passive aggressive review
in Google Translate
asking why I didn't fucking say I got it.
And I was like,
"I don't think it's that
big of a deal is it?"
Sure, I didn't reply, it's all good right?
You did your job.
I paid you the money and it's fine.
'Cause he gets the money immediately so.
- Yeah, so you'd think
that if he got the money,
then that means it arrived safely, right?
- Yeah and also it was weird
'cause you can't use a normal
email for Yahoo Auction.
- No, you have to use Yahoo account.
- And I don't have notifications set up,
so I didn't see it so,
but I got my Jojo figure.
I got my Jojo figure.
- Is that the only thing you
bought off Yahoo Auction?
- No, he bought the
drip shirt thing right?
- Oh no, sorry, that's Mercari, sorry.
- Oh, that's Mercari, oh okay.
- Yeah, 'cause there's tons of it
but the prices were like totally wild
and also getting the size was difficult
'cause I want to get an L size.
'Cause it's a jacket
so I don't mind if it's a little big,
'cause it looks cool, it's drip.
Bro, it's drip. Drip.
But all the ones in Japan were S or M.
I couldn't find anyone who had a fucking L
and there was one that was L
and it happened to be the cheapest one
so I was like, "This is an absolute win."
- 'Cause no ones big
enough here to wear the L.
- Yeah, right? I was like this is amazing.
Fantastic. Yeah, it was great.
- That is the big problem
about just clothes sizes in America.
Not America.
- Just in Japan.
Trash Taste takes any
opportunity to mock America.
- America just is in my head constantly.
Oh no, in Asia.
- You said that sentence
like it was pre programmed.
- Yeah, I know right?
It's just muscle memory at this point.
- So I hate America, but actually-
- I'm not shitting on America right now.
(laughing)
No, yeah like especially shoe sizes,
shoe sizes are like fucking impossible.
- I can't buy shoes here, dude.
- Yeah, I know.
- Its fucking impossible.
- You have to go to
like a specialized store
and just like pray,
pray that they have the shoe size.
- I'm like the maximum.
- Yeah, the only store
I've ever found in Japan
that has shoes my size is
the ABC Mart in Shinjuku.
- Oh yeah, that's like-
- Which is where most
of the foreigners are.
- You gotta get to where all
the foreigners are, right?
- Yeah, I can't buy that shit online.
I can't buy it like anywhere
outside of Shinjuku.
It's fucking stupid
because there's so many
like amazing collabs as well
that like the fucking New Balance collab
that they did with Eva,
I was so pissed off
because they had like these nice Eva shoes
and I was like "Oh, what
size does it go up to?"
And he's like, "Oh, 26."
I'm like, "Do you have
any 29 and a halfs?"
- 26 is really small.
- Yeah, 26 is tiny.
- You know, I wish shirts came in sizes
like shoe sizes, right?
- No.
- I do because okay,
you get an S, you get an M, you get an L-
- Logistical nightmare of that though.
- What does that, that
means different things
depending on what country you're in.
- Well, we should have,
I agree that we should have
some form of uniform rules
on what S, M and L is
but then I guess not
every country would agree
'cause you know the normal in America
is totally different
to the normal in Japan.
- I get an L in Japan, it's too small.
Like the first Jojo suits I bought,
it was an L and it was too small, right?
I get an L in the US,
it's like three sizes too big.
I'm just like, what?
Like at least with shoe
sizes it's a number
which I can correlate to something.
With like shirt sizes and suit sizes,
it's like a fucking free for all
depending on what country you're in
and you have to hope,
you have to hope that the
store you're buying from
is a local Japanese produced store.
If you're buying American
shirts in a Japanese store,
then you're still fucked
because you're buying American sizes.
So you gotta got to make sure.
- But shoes do the same thing.
You have UK sizes, you have
US sizes, you have JP sizes.
- Yeah, but there is a
conversion chart for it.
So it's like all universal shoes,
I've never had a problem with.
I know if they have it in my size.
When I'm buying clothes in Japan online,
it's a fucking lottery man.
I'm just like, is it the M or the L?
Or is it the LL? Fuck, it
could be either one, man.
It could be either one.
- Now, the worse ones
are the ones that don't
even use like S, M or L.
The ones that use like one,
two, three, four, five,
and I'm like what does that mean?
What does that actually mean?
- And they're just like, "Oh,
we have the size conversion
charts on the website."
I'm just like,
"Who the fuck uses a size
conversion chart for T-shirts?!"
Do you know a single person
who wants to buy a T-shirt
and they're just all right, let
me get the tape measure out,
all right, yeah.
- So what's the shoulder
width of an M size?
- I hate the whole tall, short
nonsense with coffee as well.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like tall is not the biggest one
but it sounds tall and
then grande's medium
and then what's the big one?
Venti.
- [Garnt] Venti.
- [Joey] Venti.
- What the fuck does any
does any of this shit mean?
I get it's Italian right?
- Yeah.
- But like, fuck that.
(Garnt laughing)
- Just do small, medium,
large, extra large.
- We've had this, like you know,
we don't do like fucking hot or cold
in some other language.
We just do hot or cold.
And the rules aren't uniform
in the coffee shop or whatever.
Why are we changing the fucking rules?
What's up with that?
- [Man] Apparently there's
another size bigger,
it's called trenta.
- Like when you pay,
you don't pay in fucking euro, do you?
- It just sounds fancy.
- Yeah, it just sounds fancy.
- This is what I hate,
it's like why are you turning
an agreed upon standard
into like your fucking passion project
for your chain?
You know what I mean? I hate it.
- That's why until I got
fucking used to the whole like,
especially Starbucks sizes,
'cause I never went to
Starbucks in Australia.
The first time I went to
America and I was like,
"Oh yeah, I'll get the tall.
That's that's the biggest one, right?"
I got this pissy little thing
and I was like all right.
Next time I went I was like,
"Biggest size, please."
- Big size.
- So you know in the UK,
sometimes I would order the venti size
'cause it was a reasonably big.
- Hmm.
- Yeah, yeah.
- One time I made the
mistake at Anime Expo
of ordering a venti size
at Starbucks in America,
and I swear I heard
fucking boss music playing
when they were like serving
this fucking drink to me.
It took like four of them
to fucking hold it up.
This massive Frappuccino.
- It's like a bucket.
- It was like one liter of
ice cream in this Frappuccino.
I was like, "Fucking hell,
how many calories is in this?"
I went online.
It was something like 2,100 calories.
2,100!
Holy shit.
- What's wrong, doll?
You haven't touched your
bucket of ice cream yet.
- What's wrong, honey?
You haven't touched your
Oreo Baskin-Robbins,
2000 calorie milkshake.
It was insane.
How could they serve this?
How is that legal?
- I don't know.
- Yeah,
on the flip side though,
coffee sizes in Japan, way too small.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
Yeah, this is the biggest one.
- This is a large size.
This is a standard large size
that you'd find in any
Japanese coffee shop.
- It's the biggest they have.
But here's the problem, right, in Japan.
Sometimes, this just normally
what I always want now.
This is like the size that
I've gotten accustomed to
and I actually quite like it.
It's like a good amount.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I feel like I got a
good milk to coffee ratio.
And now I always order the
largest thing they have
because it's normally like this,
but then I get caught off
guard when you go to a place
and you order the large
and then it's like, "Oh
shit, it's actually large."
Fuck, I didn't expect this.
(laughing)
I don't know, I have no
idea what the large is.
Some coffee shops, MVPs.
They have like a little display
that has the small, medium and large.
- Yeah, like the cups, right? Yeah.
- What a nice MVP I can visualize
how much coffee or drink
I'm going to receive.
- Well, there are some places
where they like show you how
many milliliters it is, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Those ones are like nice.
Yeah.
- It's like going to an
American restaurant in Japan
and it's just like, well,
it's an American restaurant
so is it gonna be American sizes
or is it gonna be Japanese sizes?
Because if it's gonna be Japanese sizes,
I'm gonna need to order an appetizer.
If it's American sizes, you
don't need to order that shit.
- The appetizer is the meal.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Bro, yeah, I ordered fucking
nachos at the Hard Rock Cafe
and the nachos was like, my God,
you could fit like four
children on this plate.
It was insane and it
was just my appetizer,
I thought was gonna be a little bit.
I could eat the nachos
and everyone at the table could
have eaten the nachos alone
and we'd been full, and
it was free refills.
- In Japan.
- Yeah, in Japan.
- Oh wow.
- That's what gets you, right?
'Cause you expect Japanese sizes in Japan,
but whenever it's like American style,
you go to some American styled restaurants
and it's still like
Japanese sizes, you know?
But you go to some
American style restaurants
and they ain't playing around.
They're going all the way.
- Full assimilation.
- They're fully assimilated
to American culture
through and through.(laughing)
- Oh my God.
- Imagine though, I mean,
we're already used to all that.
Imagine like, just like an innocent,
like Japanese girl being like,
"Oh, I heard about this
thing called Hard Rock Cafe.
(laughing)
I'm quite hungry. Let's
get the biggest size."
She just gets a fucking mammoth of food.
- Well, 'cause it wasn't expensive either.
So that's why I was kind of like normally-
- Misleading, right?
- Normally like the price to,
like if the appetizers like 15 bucks,
I'm like okay, it's
probably gonna either be
like really high quality
ingredients or something,
or it's gonna be pretty big.
And it's probably normally pretty big.
And it was massive. It was gargantuan.
I could like, again, I
could hear the boss music
like fucking Sephirot theme playing
as they were all bringing it out.
It was like that meme of
like the chess grandmaster
versus the kid in the Russian TV show.
It was like that.
"I heard you wanted a large,
so we prepared a bucket for you, Connor!"
(Joey humming)
(Joey laughing)
It's like a quick time event.
I'm gonna fucking try and
do something to survive.
- Yeah, I just remembered like
the first time I went to America,
it completely blew my mind
just like the scale of the meals.
I wasn't prepared, right?
Because I had always heard about it.
- I think we have spoken
about this before, right?.
- There's never ending stories about that.
- I mean, yeah because like
I'd heard about it before
but I don't think anything
can fully prepare you
for the first time that first
plate gets put in front of you
and you just think this is
food that I need to consume.
Like I remember,
I remember like the first
time I went to America,
it was like the first week
and I needed something that just
wasn't just greasy or you
know, wasn't too filling.
- [Connor] Impossible.
- A hard task.
- By that time I'd like
eaten like burgers and pizzas
and fucking Denny's or whatever every day,
so I'm just like I just
want something healthy.
I want something light.
I want a light lunch.
So we're at this diner.
- An oxymoron in America.
- Yeah, we were at this diner
and I was like, "What's the
lightest thing they have?"
Well, it's possibly a salad, right?
There's no way you can make a salad
not anything but a light lunch.
And I was like, "I'm safe, I'm safe.
I'll order the salad."
And then I remember just walking out
and I see this fucking
massive bowl in front of me
and I'm just like,
"Who the fuck deforested
the Amazon rainforest
and put it on my bowl?"
Like how have Americans found a way
to make salads unhealthy
because like they fucking
drenched that shit
in dressing, right?
And I'm just like what? How?
How is this possible?
- I think if you want to go
any healthier than that,
you just have to like get
just a bucket of water,
you can't get any healthier than that.
It's like healthy? What's that?
You want some water?
This episode is sponsored by Cosori
- Garnt, why on earth
did you have an air fryer
on the Trash Taste set?
- Because it's a sponsor, Connor.
(Connor Gasping)
- What? Is this episode
is sponsored by Cosori?
- It is.
- Wow!
Cosori is a best selling
kitchen brand on Amazon
and the signature Cosori air fryer
and Cosori Gooseneck kettle
are right here right in front of us.
- Oh my God!
- You know what?
Let's take a look inside
the air fryer, guys.
- Please.
- Holy shit!
- Oh!
- Is that some hot chicken wings?
- Ooh, damn!
Are those crispy without
being overly oily?
May I have a bite of it?
- Let me have a taste.
- Oh my god.
This smells amazing.
- Yeah, it actually smells really good,
let me give it a bite.
- Guys, is it me or is
this just delicious,
crispy and not too oily?
- This Cosori air fryer
has a quick basket feature
where you can actually detach the basket
from the tray with ease.
- Ooh!
- Damn son!
- Get outta here.
And gamers, we can't forget
the Cosori Gooseneck kettle
has a precise temperature control.
I mean, now we're drinking green tea
and there's a green tea
setting right there.
So whatever beverage you're enjoying,
there is the perfect temperature
control option for it.
- Ooh.
- Oh.
- That Gooseneck, you get
really like in-depth there.
Ooh!
- Oh my! (sipping)
Now, that is the perfect
green tea temperature.
- Hell yeah, it is, gentlemen.
- If you're looking for
that perfect culinary gift
for that cook in your life,
check out Cosori's holiday
sale on Amazon today.
Link's in the description.
- Thank you Cosori for
sponsoring this episode,
back to the show.
- Man, I love wings in the US.
I love wings.
- Oh no.
- Buffalo?
- Yeah, but like you never know-
(phone buzzing)
Oh my God, Garnt.
- Sorry.
- You never know how many
wings you're getting sometimes
which is always the hard part.
Sometimes they don't say
how many wings you get.
- Right.
- Which I hate
and also sometimes you don't
know how beefy the wings are.
Sometimes you get like final boss wings.
Sometimes you get like level
one starter Pokemon wings.
- Do you like Buffalo Wild Wings?
- I love Buffalo Wild Wings.
- I feel like in America
like fuck me, man.
Like, 'cause in the UK,
I feel like in the UK and in Europe
we have like regular size wings
or like normal, like
average size wings, right?
Because some places in Thailand,
you order chicken wings
or you order like chicken
and you're just like man,
this chicken's fucking anorexic, you know?
- Yeah Japan, all the
wings here are anorexic.
- Yeah, you're fucking fighting
to get all the fucking
meat off the bones, man.
- It's basically frogs legs.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Meanwhile in America it's like,
oh, is this an albatross?
(Garnt laughing)
Like this boy's got a fucking wingspan.
- Yeah, how much did
this chicken deadlift?
Bro, what the fuck.
(all laughing)
- I don't know.
- It's just like the fucking
Tyler1 of chickens, right?
(all laughing)
- Thick and chonky.
I don't know, like I went
to Buffalo Wild Wings once
and it's like, I don't
know if I like it or not.
- I love Buffalo Wild Wings.
- See, the problem I have with
Buffalo Wild Wings is that
like they shouldn't call
it Buffalo Wild Wings.
They should call it Buffalo Wild Sauce
because there is more sauce on that wing
than there is actual wing.
- Yeah. Okay.
I've been a few times 'cause
I really like going there.
'Cause you get like craft
beer and stuff as well.
- That's fine.
- I'm like I'm already becoming
a 40 year old white dad.
I'm already on my way there.
I love Buffalo Wild Wings.
I love craft beer so much
and like wings goes so well with it.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- I don't mind
if it's bone or boneless,
I don't mind.
I just prefer bone.
- On bone, on bone.
- I just like, I just
don't like, I don't know.
The sauce is like too overpowering.
- Sometimes. Yeah, yeah.
- It depends what sauce you get.
- And then sometimes they
have the audacity to be like,
"Would you like extra sauce?"
I'm like "No, I'm good."
- Sometimes you get a sauce
that's so goddamn good
you're like, bro, I don't mind
that they lathered this on.
You know what I mean?
- Maybe it's just the sauce
I got was kind of meh.
- Maybe.
Like Buffalo Wild Wings in my experience
have had a lot of sauces where
I'm like, "This is shit."
- Yeah, maybe I just got the shit one.
- Like sometimes like
the honey mustard one,
sometimes honey mustard
is a hit or a miss for me.
Sometimes it's done right.
Sometimes it just tastes
like artificial as fuck.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it's awful.
But yeah.
You know what I really
wished we had in Japan?
- [Garnt] What?
- Spicy food challenges.
We have like, there's so many
big food challenges in Japan.
- We do have spicy food challenges.
- Where?
- Like most ramen shops.
- Are they like actual challenges
or are they like we have a spicy ramen?
- No, there's ones that are like actually-
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Is that spicy for you
Joey, or like actually spicy?
- Like we're talking like ghost pepper--
- I don't know, I think for you guys
it needs to be like nuclear level
for you to be like "Ooh, that's a little,
mm, that hits back."
- I'd love to do a video where I go to
like a spicy food challenge place,
but I haven't been able
to find anything yet.
- I've seen a lot of like,
there was like entire
programs on Japanese TV
that were about that.
- I saw one ramen shop
that did spicy ramen.
- Yeah.
- But it didn't advertise it
as like if you complete
it, you get something.
It was like, we just have
a really spicy ramen,
you can order it.
- Oh.
- I feel like the part of
the charm of the challenge
is that there's like, you
get it for free or, you know?
- Right.
- There's a challenge to it.
- Yeah, there's some kind
of reward there, you know?
'Cause then then I feel like the video
can like have a cycle.
- The only one I know, it's not in Japan,
it's in Korea.
- Okay.
- There's this like restaurant.
I think some YouTuber did a video on it,
but there's this restaurant
in Korea that's like,
it serves like tonkotsu
but it's like insanely spicy tonkotsu
and it's like if you complete
it within like a certain time,
then you get, I think it's like,
if you complete it within five minutes
you can eat there for free for six months.
- What?
- And it's apparently so spicy
that there's only been one person
who's ever completed
it under five minutes,
and the rest of them
have gone to hospital.
- What?
- Because it's so spicy.
Apparently when you walk
into this restaurant,
the first thing they give
you is a carton of milk
and like a stomach medicine.
(Connor laughing)
- You want to do that, Joey?
You want to do that?
- No, I'm good, bro.
- What if I found one in Japan,
do you wanna do it, Joey?
Just take a little sip, you
don't have to eat it all.
Just take a little bite.
- Yeah, maybe.
- You're like I am done.
- There was a part of me when,
'cause like I grew up
watching a lot of those
kinds of like programs on
TV and it was hilarious.
I'm like there was like 1%
of my brain that was like,
"You should do it for a video."
- Yeah.
- Yeah.,
- And I'm like curse you, content brain.
- Because you'd actually
be suffering for it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Great, now that I said
it on the fucking podcast.
We're gonna be bombarded for it now.
- Get Joey to do it, force him.
- I'll do it if you guys do it with me.
- [Garnt & Connor] Yeah, sure, sure.
- Just to show how much
of a pussy I really am.
- Yeah, because when I had the
ghost pepper on live streams,
people were like "Oh, that can't be real.
It can't be real ghost pepper."
- It was a real ghost pepper.
- Connor badly reacted.
- It's 'cause you're white.
- Yeah, because I'm white
they don't want to believe
that I can handle it
because I've fucked my body
by eating too much of
these fucking peppers.
- But I feel like with
a lot of white people...
- That's true. No, go ahead.
No fault taken.
- No, it's either like
one extreme or the other.
'Cause it's either like people
like you who've like actively
searched for it and they've
just like nuked their body.
- Or people that say that water is spicy.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But we had all the "Hot Ones" sauces,
right, at your house?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I was like lathering the hottest one
on my burgers and stuff and
like it wasn't that bad.
Like it was kind of nice.
Like it wasn't that spicy.
And now I watch the show and
I'm like, "It's not that bad."
I like coated a burger.
- Yeah, I want to do the
"Hot Ones" challenge.
- Yeah but I'd have to like pretend.
Oh geeze, it's getting kind of hot!
Meanwhile, I'm just like.
- Delicious.
- No because I feel like
you'd have to like up the ante
because if you just take
like one little dab,
that's not gonna do anything.
If you like fucking coat it,
then you'll probably get some
kind of sensation from it.
- I mean, I completely
lathered a burger up with it
and it was fine, but I
feel like I'd need like,
what's the one that's
like apparently horrible?
Its like the extract, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- That's like the extreme one.
- That's the extract.
- The sauce.
- Yeah, it's like pure capsaicin extract.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I want to try that.
It's not real though,
it's just your brain.
It's just your brain making shit up.
- It's your brain, isn't it? Yeah.
- Like if you think you're
gonna go into shock,
you'll go into shock.
(Joey laughing)
Just don't panic.
- Just don't go into shock.
It's simple, it's not real pain.
- You're about to have a heart attack,
it's not a real heart attack,
just tell your heart to stop.
- Bro, you're scared?
Just don't be scared.
- Just don't die.
- Just don't be scared.
- Just get a strong hart.
- It's literally fake.
- Mind over matter.
- It's literally fake
news. Bro, you're good.
- Why do people die from beestings?
Just don't be allergic,
just don't be allergic.
- Okay, a bee sting is actual
physical chemical reaction.
There's nothing-
- Is spice not a chemical reaction?
- No, it's your brain,
it's your brain making the pain.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Did you not know that?
- Wait, wait, wait.
No, 'cause I noticed like
not a single person has died from spice.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] I think.
- It's a reaction that your brain
sends to the receptors
saying that you have pain
but there's no actual reaction going on
that's causing you pain.
It's your brain telling your
body that it's happening.
- But you can die from the shock.
- [Connor] No.
- Can you not?
- Okay, so you can die
from going into shock
in general, right?
So you can die from that,
but like the pepper alone
will not 'cause you to go into shock.
It's like your brain, you
panicking and freaking out
will 'cause you to die.
- Right.
- It's like telling someone
who's having a panic attack
just not to panic.
That works, right?
- But like generally you
won't die from a panic attack
unless you're having like heart problems.
- No, it's impossible to
die from a panic attack
unless they were like-
- You have like cardiac arrest.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- But like the odds of someone our age
having cardiac arrest is like super low.
You'd have to really have
an unhealthy lifestyle
and also be in extreme shock.
I think I'm correct in saying
this, I could be wrong.
There might be doctors watching this,
but as far as far as I'm
aware, like it's, you know,
this whole thing-
- Don't take our word for this.
- This is not medical advice,
this is not medical advice,
I don't know what I'm saying.
- This is definitely the
opposite of medical advice.
- As far as I know this whole-
- Medical risk.
- This whole thing of
like yeah, you can die.
Like I think you can faint
but I think you can faint from like
being like just absolutely exhausted
and freaking out and panicking.
Like I'm pretty sure
you can't die from it.
- Are we talking about spice now?
- Spice, yeah.
- Yeah. Okay.
- I'm pretty sure if you're healthy
and you're under a certain age
and you have no heart
problems, you'll be fine.
- Well, suffice to say
I don't eat spicy food
because I'm afraid of dying.
I just don't enjoy it.
- No, understandable, right?
Like it's just gotten to
the point for me where like,
when I have something
that is like particularly,
if it's saucy or meaty,
something about having spice on it
just elevates it so much.
- No, it does.
There are some dishes that I feel-
- Curry especially.
- Yeah, yeah.
Some dishes I feel that
are just made for spice
and yeah, we can do the spice challenge
but like I genuinely
enjoy spice with my food,
with a lot of food.
It depends on the dish, right?
Because like for example,
if you go to CoCo ICHIBANYA,
they have like the spice scale, right?
And you can get the
level 10, that's spicy,
but I feel like at that
level, it's just spicy.
- It's not enjoyable
- It's not enjoyable.
It's spicy for the sake of being spicy.
- It just hurts and it just
ruins the taste of the food.
- I've heard between level five and 10,
it doesn't really change
in terms of the flavor.
- Ah.
I normally get seven when I go.
That's normally like
a happy medium for me.
10 is just like too much pain.
I don't know what they put in it at 10.
- I can't explain it, the
spice just feels artificial.
It doesn't feel like real spice
it just feels like well,
you're just kind of adding
some kind of chemical to make this spicy.
I don't know what they
do to make it more spicy
but like I grew up on obviously
Thai dishes and Thai food
and it just feels like some dishes
are just made for spice, right?
If you remove like the chilies
or the aspects of spice from some dishes,
you're losing part of that
dish in my opinion, right?
- I saw a picture and it was
like from a Thai restaurant
'cause apparently Thai's known
for being the spiciest foods in the world.
- Oh really?
- I believe it.
- Apparently so.
- It's either like Thai or like
Indian or something, right?
- Or Mexican maybe.
- Chinese, maybe like Szechwan.
- Szechwan? Szechwan is like
a different kind of spice.
- Yeah, it's like peppercorn spice.
- It's peppercorn spice.
It like numbs your tongue.
- There was like a,
it was a picture outside
of a Thai restaurant
there was like, "We will
no longer give refunds
if your food is too spicy."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
And apparently it happens all the time.
People have returned
food to Thai restaurants
because it's too spicy.
- In Thailand?
- No, in like America and
Europe and stuff like that.
- Okay, yeah, yeah.
No, that's how you know it's
a true Thai restaurant, man.
- Yeah, yeah. That's the
true Thai experience.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I understand that if it's that spicy
you can't eat it but at
the same time it's like,
hmm, yeah, well, you are ordering a food
and if you want the native food,
you are gonna get it
- Yeah.
- Yeah, like it hurts my soul a bit
because at our restaurant,
at my family restaurant,
we have to like make sure
the spice is less spicy-
- Do you offer like the original spice?
- Of course, of course.
If they ask for it but you know,
part of my soul dies inside.
- If they can speak Thai.
- Yeah, part of my soul
dies inside just knowing
that we're serving less
spicy dishes to everyone
because they can't handle, it man.
- [Connor] That does hurt, that does hurt.
- 'Cause that's just not the true dish
and to me, it does
actually hurt the flavor.
To me it's like actually like
having sushi without wasabi
or something, you know?
- Sometimes I don't have wasabi.
You don't always need the-
- That hurts my soul.
- Horseradish wasabi sucks
dick man, it's awful.
It's tastes like shit.
- Well you're not going to
the good restaurants then.
- No, sometimes I want
the 100 yen sushi, man.
- Well, that's what you get then,
that's what you paid for.
- Get off my case. Get
off my fucking case.
- Man can buy a thousand dollar drip shirt
but can only afford a 100 yen sushi.
- Listen, that is a business
investment, all right?
I don't want to hear it from you, J.
That is more than just a jacket,
that is a historical art
piece that I purchased, Joey.
- You sound like someone who buys NFTs.
- No, no, no.
(Garnt laughing)
- That is not just a gif of yawn cat,
it is a historical art piece.
- Dude, you can't right
click, save that jacket.
You can right click, save in NFT.
That doesn't apply.
This also doesn't ruin the environment.
- Right.
- This is a historical piece.
In 10 years, this will
be a monumentous jacket
that I will make sure everybody
remembers single handedly.
- Monumentous? (laughing)
- This is a piece of meme history.
- Is that a word?
- This is a piece of meme history, Joey.
- I don't know, man, it's
like stained and ripped.
- Oh no, no, you can't say that.
- Second hand right?
- Yeah.
- You can't see it, bro.
I'll take pictures in 360p.
- Next time I go to
your house, I'll see it.
I'll see that rip.
- Get some Japanese to grade it.
- It's like a Mona Lisa, right?
It's got a story, it's been robbed once,
had little scuffs here and there,
it adds to the character of the piece.
So, that to me is not a jacket,
it is an encapsulation of
our time and meme history.
- Has everyone screenshoted
this for poorly aged things?
Do it now.
- This is meme history.
If there was other memes where
I could buy a physical thing,
I would buy it as well.
- What's a meme do you think
that is historical then?
That is already historical.
- Yeah.
- Harambe.
- No.
- Harambe is historical.
- No, really?
- No way.
- That's a meme that is,
if you're a memer you know Harambe.
- Yeah, but that's the
same thing as like fucking-
- That doesn't make it historical.
- It's historical. Harambe's historical.
- Just because you know it.
- Harambe's historical.
- Like there was so
little memes at that time
that every meme is historical
because like back then
there would be like 10 memes
in the entire fucking year.
- Deez nuts?
Deez nuts a milestone of comedy and memes.
- Unfortunately there's
nothing physical you can buy
for deez nuts.
- Deez nuts is an idea man,
it's a concept.
It can't be owned by the people!
(Joey laughing)
It belongs to the people!
It can't be owned by a single person!
- Our nuts. (laughing)
- Well, the drip jacket belongs
to Goku first and foremost,
and then me second, nobody else.
- Can a meme really be owned though?
Can it be owned, Connor?
- You can participate in the meme.
I'm fueling the meme economy.
- The meme economy.
- If that jacket wasn't a meme,
I wouldn't buy it.
You know what I mean?
- I don't think anyone would.
- No, it looks kind of cool.
I mean.
I thought how much it was at retail,
it might have been $400.
- You think that meme's gonna
be remembered in two years?
If it then it's like,
that has staying power as a meme.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- To be fair, the Drip Goku meme
has weirdly lasted a long time,
like it pops up a lot.
- Yeah, I feel it's because you can fit it
into anything, right?
- Yeah, because 'cause
drip has lasted awhile,
it goes hand in hand with drip.
If drip is around Goku Drip is around.
'Cause he is the embodiment
of the word drip.
- Yeah, like what memes has prevailed
for like past two years?
Has there been any meme?
- There probably has.
Deez nuts has lasted a very long time.
- It's 'cause this guy just
won't let it fucking die.
- No, 'cause everyone.
Deez nuts is literally-
- I don't even count Deez nuts as a meme.
- But it's gotten so popular.
- It's just a thing you say.
- It gets more popular like every month.
- It's like Minecraft,
it died off and now it's
like having a resurgence man.
It's just...
(Joey laughing)
- Minecraft music, Minecraft song.
Who's that guy who sings
Minecraft songs really badly?
- What?
- There's a guy who sings like
Minecraft parodies something.
He sings really amazing
Minecraft parody songs
with a shit mic.
It's amazing.
- That sounds funny already.
- Is that the same guy who
made the "Fortnite" song?
- No, "Chug Jug With You"?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that didn't last long.
That lasted like two
months, remember that?
- Yeah.
- I remember that.
- [Man] Nyan Cat is history. Nyan Cat.
- Only because of the NFTs, right?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Well Nyan Cat is history
just because at that time-
- It was inescapable.
- It was inescapable
and there wasn't anything
to compete with it.
If Nyan Cat came out like today,
people would forget it
in like a millisecond.
- We should do a three by three of memes.
- We should, we should.
(laughing)
I don't even think Harambe
was like that funny though.
- It wasn't funny but it
was just around for a while
and it came back a lot.
- Did it?
- Yeah.
- Did it come back?
- I can't...
- I'm Googling most
popular memes of all time.
- I'm trying to remember
like funny Harambe memes.
- Troll Face.
- Well, I mean, that
was like the beginning.
- But now that's just like cringe right?
- Dat Boi.
- Oh, I love Dat Boi, dude!
Oh shit, what up, it's Dat Boi!
I still have a Dat Boi T-shirt.
- Now, that makes me feel
like a fucking boomer.
Oh my God.
- I still have a T-shirt of Dat Boi.
- No, is it weird that
you think of Troll Face
and you feel like a boomer?
You think of Dat Boi,
you definitely feel like a millennial.
(both laughing)
That's like a generational meme gap,
but they're both like still cringe now.
- I don't know, something about Dat Boi,
it was just like a funny image.
Like you couldn't use it in any memes.
The only time I ever
saw like a Dat Boi meme
that was actually funny was like
someone took like the movie poster
for "The Boy in Striped Pajamas"
and just called it "Dat Boi
in the Striped Pajamas."
(laughing)
It's the only one that made me laugh,
everything else is just fucking stupid.
It's a frog on a unicycle.
- I'm going through all of these.
- What about Rage Comics?
Is that a meme?
- Yeah.
- Is that a meme?
- Well, that's the OGs right?
- Yeah, well they had the
Troll Face and all that.
- Troll Face and then like Forever Alone.
- Troll Face is pretty iconic.
420, 69, all that stuff?
- Is that a meme?
- I think so.
420 is a meme like straight up.
- I guess.
- And 420 has somehow prevailed
even though it's like not that funny.
- It's kind of like just a
public holiday right now.
It's the closest we're gonna get
to a meme public holiday, right?
The one day we come together
and celebrate a meme.
- Meme Day is April the 20th.
- I'm going through all of these.
- Do you think like our kids
are still gonna be saying 420?
- Oh God, probably.
- I hope not.
- They're probably gonna
find it cringe, right?
- Hey dad, 420.
(laughing)
It's like, "Shut up son."
You don't know the
meaning behind that word.
- But I feel like sometimes
memes come back around
and become funny again, right?
'Cause you know,
with the Ancient Memes Twitter account
I've found Rage Comics funny again.
- It's true.
- It's like ironically funny now, right?
- Rickrolling.
- That's a classic meme.
- True, true. That is the classic meme.
- Probably the most classic and-
- [Man] Unexpected.
- No, not unexpected.
It's always expected.
It's the most long lasting prevalent meme.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And this one's obvious,
but like pretty much every
fucking SpongeBob screenshot.
Out of any show, somehow
SpongeBob has the most memes.
- It is a meme factory.
- And they're good.
They're good, they're really good.
Like think of all the,
some of the funniest meme screenshots,
like 50% of them are from SpongeBob.
- Oh yeah.
- That's true, that's true.
- It's insane.
- He was ahead of his time, man.
- Bro, SpongeBob was-
- SpongeBob invented memes.
- Felt different, man.
Yeah, I guess in terms of the long lasting
it's probably 420 in my mind,
SpongeBob and probably Rickrolling
are some of the three
most powerful influential.
Influential.
- And you can't own them.
- You can't own them.
- Belongs to nobody, Connor.
- I'm gonna have to make
Drip Goku stay around
for a long time so I can
get some like investment.
But okay, if you try to sell the jacket
in like a year right,
it'd be worth more, right?
If the meme is still popular?
if the meme's still popular.
I'm not gonna sell it though.
I'm owning history.
- You're hodling, man.
- No. Diamond hands!
No, I actually want to wear it.
- If you're not gonna sell them,
why are we talking about
the durability of a meme?
- I'm just saying like you know,
there are some memes that where
it's hard to gauge whether
it will stick around or not,
and most of them-
- It's 'cause 99% of them don't.
Like you remember how quickly
the fucking cake meme died?
- What cake meme?
- Where everything is cake.
Do you remember that?
- Oh my God, that's a shit meme.
- Yeah.
But everyone was like this
is the new hottest thing,
and three days later
it's like, "What cake?"
- No, that prevailed for like a while.
- You think?
- Yeah.
- You guys don't watch "Lessons
in Meme Culture", do you?
- No, no, no.
- Basically it talks about memes
and like every single
day there's this new meme
that I've just never heard of
and dies like within a day
'cause they're like weird ass shit.
- But like can you even call
it a meme at that point?
Because like sometimes there's you know,
sometimes there's a meme
that which lasts a day.
I feel like if a meme
truly has staying power
it should like, a week is
like the minimum requirement.
- Yeah, what's the line between
a meme and an inside joke?
- Well, I think you're
confusing memes on like,
there's levels of memes right?
There's like the public memes
where everyone is in the loop.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- And then there's internet only memes
where it's only certain groups
on the internet do this meme.
- What's this meme name,
I don't know what this meme name is
but I find it fucking hilarious.
It's the one where they
take stock pictures
and make really shitty jokes with it.
- Stonks?
- No, no, no.
Like the one where-
- With the boyfriend looking behind.
- No, no, not that one.
Like-
- Hide the Pain Harold?
Stuff like that?
- No, no, no, they take stock pictures
and like, for example, there's
a girl like laying down
and a guy, and she says
call me an ambulance
and the guy like kneels over
and he says, "You're an ambulance."
(Joey laughing)
I don't know why I find those hilarious
but I don't know what
the name of that meme is
'cause I want to find more pictures
and more memes in that category.
- Is that the one where the
son and the dad are in the car
and it's like, "Oh, we named
your sister after roses
because your mum loves roses."
And he's like, "Oh,
what am I named after?"
And he's like, "Oh, you wouldn't
understand 420 blaze it"
or something.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, like that.
- My favorite one is
the, "Honey, wake up."
(laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a very popular one.
- Yeah, if anyone knows
the name of that meme
please tell me because I want to Google it
and I want to find more memes like that.
- I just call those
like stock photo memes.
- Yeah, but like stock
photo memes are so like
so wide and varied and broad
'cause you've got like
the guy looking back
and I don't count that, you know?
- Yeah.
- Well why not?
- No, because it's, you know,
what I'm talking about
is like a very specific
shitty joke that works
because you've got shitty
stock images with it.
If you've seen the meme,
if you've seen the same
images in the same category,
you will know exactly
what I'm talking about.
It's just so hard to
put like a fucking word
and a name to it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't know what the name is.
- I don't know.
- I don't know, you're
gonna have to show me these.
- Yeah.
All right.
- Do you need to pee?
- Yeah, I need to pee.
- We all shop online
and we've all seen that promo code field
taunt us at checkout but thanks to Honey,
manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past.
Honey is the free browser extension
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one
it finds to your cart.
Honey supports over 30,000 stores online
ranging from sites that have
tech and gaming products
to popular fashion brands
and even food delivery.
Guys, what did you buy?
- I'm glad you asked, Joey.
I recently acquired drip.
It might be hard to tell.
I don't know, but I recently got drip
and I saved a significant
amount of money thanks to Honey.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Here's how it works.
- Tell me.
- Imagine you're shopping at
one of your favorite sites.
- Yeah-huh.
- While at the checkout,
the Honey button drops down
and all you have to do
is click "Apply coupons."
- [Joey] Oh my god.
- [Garnt] Wait a few seconds
as Honey searches for all the coupons
it can find for that site.
- Bro.
- If Honey finds a working coupon
you'll watch as the prices drop.
- Oh my God!
- So what are you doing?
Get your drip.
(Joey laughing)
Honey has found it's
over 17 million members
$2 billion in savings.
- Sheesh!
- So, guys what are you waiting for?
If you don't already have Honey,
you can be straight up
missing out on free savings.
It's literally free and it
installs in a few seconds,
and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid
and supporting Trash Taste and the boys.
So what are you waiting for?
Get Honey for free at
joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste
- Thank you to Honey for
sponsoring the episode.
Back to the show.
- So "League of Legends."
(all laughing)
- Yes Garnt, what about it?
- I'm just gonna drown myself real quick.
- What about it?
- So Joey,
have you heard of this new anime
or animated series called "Arcane"?
- Is the "League of
Legends" anime I assume?
- It is the "League of Legends."
- I've seen pictures of it yeah.
- Okay, so at the time of recording
only the first three episodes are out.
So it might be a massive failure
if the next six came out.
So we don't know.
But after the first three episodes
it looks and was really fucking good,
like really good.
- Yeah, it looks good.
- The visuals are insane.
- It is genuinely like I came into this
'cause, you know, me and
Connor both play "League",
you know?
- We're both toxic.
- Yeah, we're both very
toxic gamers in that sense
and every time we talk about "League"
Joey just like just like conks out.
So what I was expecting was
just a mediocre video game-
- Fan servicey.
- Yeah, fan servicey adaptation.
I just wanted some cool fight scenes
basically just like an extended version
of the "League" cinematics,
you know what I mean?
- [Joey & Connor] Yeah.
- And I would have been happy,
but like I watched the
first three episodes
and I was just so unprepared
for what I think is like one of like,
so this is just watching three episodes,
it's legitimately like
the best three episodes
of like any show I've watched this year.
I can't think of like a show
that just has a stronger start.
- I agree.
It was like an, oh my God.
Like the visuals are like Pixar level
of like detail at times
into like a nine episode show.
- Yeah.
- I just don't understand
how they're doing it.
Like the animation is insane.
- Yeah Joey look,
I know you've like quit anime
and everything like that
but I swear to God this is something that
even if you have zero
interest in "League."
- It literally doesn't matter.
- Even if fucking hate "League"
you need zero fucking
knowledge about the game
because it's all about...
I love that I focuses on
like the character and worlds
because what this series made me realize
is that "League" actually has
a really fucking interesting world
and that's what really drew me in,
which was there was so much thought
that was put into the
world building and the lore
which is like "League" lore
was like the meme for the longest time.
- It was a mess because
they kept rewriting it
because they would introduce
characters and then aw, no.
So they had like this mess of characters
that people really like with
really interesting backstories,
but they didn't really
know how to like connect it
and then they just literally
at one point just gave up,
they just stopped doing it.
- Right, right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They're like all right,
no one's reading it.
They used to do like
articles all the time.
Do you remember?
- And no one read it.
- 'Cause it was a mess.
'Cause it made like no, I
mean, it did make sense,
but it was just so
confusing and hard to digest
that the only way people consumed it
was through YouTube videos
of people explaining it.
- Yeah.
- And I think most players
didn't really care to begin with, right?
- No, fuck no.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And no one's playing
"League" for the lore.
- No, it's like how many like curse words
can you say per minute
instead of how many
character lores do you know?
It's different but like I
think you would enjoy it
if you give it a shot, Joey.
It's not like "League" at all really.
- It's really not.
- The only benefit you get
of being a "League" fan
is that character's names come up
where you're like, "Oh,
I know that character!",
but then in the show
they're like nothing like
the character in game
so it doesn't even fucking matter.
- It doesn't matter
because a lot of the times you're guessing
is that that character?
Is that that champion?
But most of the time
they're just characters in the show,
which is what I like, right?
They don't like fan
service certain characters
because they are characters in the show.
A lot of the times there is
just this world that exists
and some people in this world
happen to be "League" characters,
and it's a show where I feel like it just,
you don't have to be
"League" fan to enjoy it
and it prevails with like
mass marketing "League"
as a franchise as
opposed to just the game.
It's like honestly,
the only video game adaptation I think
that even like stands close
to it is "Castlevania."
It's like "Castlevania" level
of like video game adaptations.
- I guess we'll have to see
where the next six episodes go
but like right now goddamn, goddamn.
I was very impressed.
- It was interesting
watching a show like this
with Twitch shout though,
because (laughing)
you'd have these like really,
really serious moments going on
and then you'd watch Twitch shout
and everyone was just
like fucking memeing.
- Jungle feeding.
- ADCFK, ADCFK.
And I'm just like okay, it's pretty fun,
but at the same time, is it
ruining my viewing experience?
I'm not quite sure.
- It was like genuinely like
a movie quality experience
watching this thing but
like in a TV series,
like everything was so on point,
like the sound design was insane.
The animation, especially.
I could go on and on about
how good the animation is.
And the voice acting's really good.
Like everything so far has been good.
Like absolute bangers.
- I know like the meme is, you know,
lol, Netflix live-action adaptation,
but man, Netflix video game adaptations
are fucking knocking it
out of the park, man.
- So far. So far.
- Again, I'm really hoping
that this doesn't age poorly-
- Yeah, I'm really hoping.
- But like, 'cause like
the episodes like as well,
like at one point I thought aw,
we're getting a predictable story,
and then it just kind of
like flips you on its head.
And it was like, "Oh! Oh, shit. Okay.
What!? Oh, Jesus!"
It's really good. Really, really good.
- Yeah, like what other
video game adaptations
have they done?
'Cause I know-
- Just "Castlevania"
so far, right?
- "Castlevania."
- What? Netflix.
- Yeah, Netflix.
- "DOTA."
- Well, they did "DOTA."
- "DOTA" had an anime?
- It was bad.
- Yeah. It wasn't good.
- Well, DOTA's a bad game too so...
- Well.
- "DOTA" fans are seething right now.
- Yeah.
I watched a little bit of the "DOTA" anime
and it wasn't good.
- But why?
- Just because I was curious.
- You should watch the "League" anime
'cause you're curious.
- I'll add it to my watch list.
- No!
- I guess-
- Please, Joey, please.
I've never wanted you to
watch an anime more than this.
- I'll watch it later.
- Please, it's good.
It's actually good!
- You know, Joey,
I actually would prefer for
you to watch "League" animation
than to watch any anime this year.
- Please, it's actually good.
Please give it a shot.
It actually so good.
- I'll be sure to check it out.
- Oh my God.
Getting this guy to watch anime
is like fucking impossible.
- It's Anime Man.
He refuses to watch an anime.
- No, I guess it settles
it though, you know?
"League" better than DOTA", right?
- Yeah, I guess so.
(all laughing)
- Checkmate "DOTA" fans.
- Well, one thing that "League"
has always been good
at was making anything
but "League" game gameplay.
Like anything that wasn't the game,
they were amazing at making.
Like every single animation
thing we got was insane.
- All the K/DA shit was fucking insane.
- Like think about fucking
everything they've made
outside of "League" is amazing.
- In terms of aside from the game,
I remember when K/DA first came out
and I'm just like, "What the fuck?
'League' is cool now?"
And I'm like that lasted for a week
and it was like the
most surreal week ever.
- Yeah.
Remember everyone was like,
"Yeah, I play 'League.'
Of course I play 'League.'"
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
- You just had the one week
where like fake "League" fans
came out where it was like
cool to play "League."
And then now it's gone back to-
- Now it's gone back, you know?
- Balanced as all things should be.
- They couldn't last.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No amount of hot K-pop girls
can get people to play that game.
- To be fair though, that K/DA
was so fucking inescapable.
- Oh, it was good.
- Oh. it was.
- But I watched it and I was like,
"Wait, do I like K-pop?"
(all laughing)
"Do I like 'League'?"
- I used to play
"League", right, way back.
- Yeah, way, way, back.
- And then Aki was like,
"Yeah, I don't play it anymore.
Not a big deal."
Then K/DA came out and Aki was like,
"Yeah, I'm a 'League' player.
Bro, I'm a 'League' player
through and through."
- Yeah, he's like
telling me all his lores,
all the K/DA characters.
I'm like, "oh, wow."
- I was like, "All right. Okay."
- The truth comes out.
- Because I remember I was actually,
'cause K/DA debuted at the 2018 final-
- Yeah, we know. Go on.
You love to tell everyone you were there.
Rub it in.
Garnt won't fucking stop telling people
that he was there when K/DA premiered.
- Yeah, no, because people ask me.
Because whenever I meet-
- Two things people ask me,
did you work at the BBC and were you at
the "League Premiere of K/DA?
- Whenever I meet a fellow "League" fan,
I'm just like, "Oh yeah, I
was at the 2018 World Final"
- And I'm always there and
I fucking roll my eyes-
- And then people ask, "Oh, how was it?"
And I'm just like, "Oh, K/DA was great."
And then they ask, "Oh, how's the match?"
I'm just like, "Oh, K/DA was great."
(Joey laughing)
'Cause I can't remember anything else.
'Cause that was the only highlight of-
- Because we lost, Garnt, we fucking lost.
- Yeah, we didn't just lose,
we got fucking obliterated, okay?
But K/DA was great.
- It's all right though.
You saw K/DA though.
That's all that matters.
- K/DA was great and that's what matters.
That was worth the
ticket and cost of flying
all the way to fucking Korea.
Korea was great.
I want to go back to Korea.
- "League" Worlds may have ended,
but the real shit was the "Arcane" anime.
That was like, end of
"League" worlds, I sleep.
"Arcane," real shit.
Bro, please, Joey,
please, I'm begging you.
Just give it a watch.
- I'll watch it.
- No, please. Actually.
- I will definitely watch it.
- I've never wanted
something more in my life.
- I will absolutely watch it.
- [Man] As a "DOTA" fan,
I give you the permission
to watch "Arcane."
(all laughing)
- As a "DOTA" fan, I give
you permission to be happy.
- Yeah, honestly, if there
are any viewers watching this
who are not a fan of "League",
even if you hate "League,"
please watch "Arcane", you know?
- If it continues to get even
better than it is right now,
which I would be impressed if it does,
it genuinely is gonna be
like a fucking hood classic.
- I wouldn't be surprised though-
- It's gonna be a certified hood classic.
- I wouldn't be surprised though
because like every, as you said,
like everything that they've
released that's not the game
has been amazing.
Like even for the people
who don't give a shit
about the game.
- I don't understand
what's going on.
- I don't understand why Riot
still pretends to be a gaming company.
(laughing)
- Genuinely because I would welcome-
- Riot, multimedia company.
- Okay, if they nail this, right?
"League" in the lore has so
many different like actions
and like, I guess, eras,
and different areas that can
completely have characters
that don't even ever
interact with each other.
And they're focusing on a certain area now
that has certain characters.
Like if this kicks it out the park,
I'm just excited for the
opportunities of like,
we could get the "League" universe-
- Yeah, the LCU, I'll be
fucking down for the LCU.
- The LCU? (laughing)
- Bro, 'cause that's
like in "League" lore,
there was like, I don't
know anything about it,
but I know there was like
a great war and stuff,
that could be fucking hype, bro.
Like bro.
- "Arcane" has made me
care about "League" lore.
Like after I've watched "Arcane,"
I started reading fucking Wiki articles
to be like, "Yo, yo, what else
can we explore?"
- It's that good, Joey.
It's that good.
- Yeah, it's such an interesting war
and there's so many
opportunities for just like
different elements to clash together
because there are some "League,"
like right now we're focusing
on like human characters
in like a city, you know,
but there are other cities,
other civilization.
And then there are just like fucking gods
in the "League" lore as well-
- Yeah, and there's
like one-off characters.
- Yeah, which I'm thinking
if they can like integrate that somehow,
then it is literally just the
MCU all over again, right?
- Yeah. I could just see it.
There's just like the fucking like,
you know how like, spoilers
for "Endgame" I guess.
You know how like Captain
America just gets his hammer?
There could be shit like that I guess,
just like, I don't know.
Zach turns into a blob
I guess, I don't know.
There's some random ass characters as well
that I would love to see
how they would integrate
There's a character in "League," right,
called Tahm Kench, right?
This whole story of this character
is that he's just a massive...
What is he a frog or some shit?
What the fuck is Tahm Kench?
- I think he's a frog.
- A massive frog-esque thing.
He just lives in a swamp, but eats humans.
And he has no connection to
like any of the characters
except for like Pyke I think.
It's just like how would
you include a character
that just eats people like that?
How would you do that? I'd love to see it.
But it's amazing because the
best thing about this character
is that he speaks in like a
really thick Southern drawl-
- Right, right, like a swamp guy.
- It's just like...
(laughing)
Well, I don't even know
what some of his lines are.
He's like, "This is my swamp. Yeah."
I don't know.
He's just like, "I'll give you a daughter"
or something like that.
I don't know, he's just
like really interesting.
I don't know.
I'd love to see how they would integrate
these weird ass characters
in the "League" lore.
- Well, I don't know how
it is for the viewers
just seeing Joe pretend, like
try his hardest to like care.
- I'm smiling through the pain.
- And if he sits here and
explains arrow games to me,
I think it's okay for me to sit here
and explain "League" lore for 10 hours.
- Look forward to my in-depth review
for next week's episode,
which is definitely coming.
- Legitimately, if you watch it,
I think you'll actually enjoy it.
- Okay.
- Like legitimately.
He'll come back and he'll be like,
"Guys, I've made a mistake."
- We're just gonna keep talking about it
until like he'll just have
to like buckle one day.
- I'm gonna read "One Piece"
and he's gonna watch this.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- That's the comparison you're gonna do?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Sure.
- This is easy to watch.
You get a treat watching this.
I haver to slog through "One Piece."
- But like, yeah, I legitimately think
it is one of the best things
I've watched this year
like anime or not,
like I can't even think of how many things
I've just watched this year.
- Not sure if that's telling
of this year's content or not.
- We've actually had some
pretty good stuff this year.
- We've had some good stuff this year.
I don't know, because I'm trying to, like-
- Yeah, I know.
(Garnt laughing)
For sure.
- I'm trying to think of all of the things
I've like read and watched
that's come out this year.
(Joey laughing)
- I can hear the dial-up.
- I mean, it's been a lot.
I'd have to like go back through because-
- Oh, it's a lot?
- Yeah.
- Oh, okay.
- Like movies has been not so much.
Movies has been not so much.
- Well, they've barely released any movies
because it's still a pandemic.
- Yeah, I mean-
- Actually, they've
really geared up recently.
I've watched a lot of movies recently.
They've been kind of been-
- It feels like
all the big movies are
just starting to come out.
- Yeah, they're just
starting to come out now
because they was supposed
to come out like a year ago.
- Yeah, like I know like
there's been some new MCU movies
that I just haven't watched.
Do you care about the MCU anymore?
- Yo, I heard "Eternals" was like bad.
- Yeah.
- "Eternals" was rated
really badly.
- Really bad.
- Yeah.
- I don't think I'm gonna watch it.
- Not that I ever gave
a shit about the MCU,
but-
- I don't.
You know, the MCU now,
it's like, okay, now
you need to prove to me
why I should care again
now that it's over...
Like to me, it's like
I don't think they can
just coast off the success
of the previous entries.
I think, yeah, sure,
we'll get like the series
that everyone's gonna go and watch
like Dr. Strange and all that stuff.
Yeah, that's gonna be cool,
but if they're trying to
sell us on new characters,
it's like, okay, how are you gonna sell us
now that there's no, at the moment,
there's no big thing that
we're planning towards?
- Yeah, like I wanted to watch
like "Shang-chi" for example,
but also I had no like incentive
to go out and watch it.
You know?
- I heard it was amazing though.
Like a lot of people
said it was really good,
but also-
- It was good.
- But also I-
- Yeah, I thought
it was really good.
- But again, you're kind
of like the same thing
where I'm like, okay, I'm not gonna lie,
a little burnt out on the
whole superhero thing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And like the only thing
I'm really excited for
superhero-wise is "Batman"
with Robert Pattinson.
- Yeah, I'm looking forward to that.
- Just 'cause I love Robert Pattinson.
I think he's so fucking
good in everything.
- I like the "Batman" movies.
Yeah, all the "Batman" movies are chill.
- But like, 'cause they've cast
like what everyone thought
was quite an unusual choice,
which like Robert
Pattinson is definitely a,
well, I mean, it's unusual.
Have you watched any of his
stuff that he's been in?
Like some of the indie
films that he's done?
- I've seen one indie film that he was in.
I forgot the name of it, but-
- What happened in it?
Roughly, do you remember or no?
- No.
- Okay.
- It was literally the
first indie film he did
after the "Twilight."
- Yeah, so obviously like
he kinda had a bad rap
from "Twilight" 'cause before
he wasn't really acting.
- Well, he was type casted as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I love interviews of him
like shitting on "Twilight."
- No, no, he fucking hates it.
- He hates it.
- Rightfully so.
- He absolutely hates it.
- I can only imagine what it felt like
where he was like I am a serious actor
who trained professionally,
went to like the most
prestigious shit in the UK
and all that, and now I'm here doing
a fucking half dead
vampire who barely emotes.
- Yeah.
- Right.
And then he went on the whole
kind of like indie film,
a bit like series where he
just did so many indie films
- He tried to change his image so hard.
- Yeah, and then he was doing
really good artistic films.
Some of them were amazing.
- Yeah.
- "The Lighthouse" was amazing
if you haven't watched that.
- No.
- Really amazing.
Highly recommend it.
It's got what's his name?
- Dafoe.
- Yeah, Willem Dafoe.
Ryuk, you may know him from
"Death Note." (laughing)
- My favorite Will Dafoe role.
- Actually like an amazing movie,
and so far I've just loved watching him.
And so I feel like he's
probably gonna do something
interesting in "Batman" that-
- A lot of type casted actors though
have gone down that route.
Like Daniel Radcliffe went down
like a massive indie film route,
because you know, everyone just knows him
as fucking Harry, right?
- When he's not busy fucking kissing
and fucking everyone on set.
- Yeah. Exactly.
No, but I went on like a massive binge
of like Daniel Radcliffe indie films.
And like some of them are fucking amazing.
Like "Kill Your Darlings"
is an amazing film.
- He did a lot of odd films.
And he did a lot of theater.
- He does a lot of stage,
yeah, theater stuff, yeah.
- 'Cause he was like,
I think it was quite a big thing in the UK
right after "Harry Potter"
ended or during "Harry Potter,"
he did something that
required him to be like naked
with like a horse or something.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I remember in the UK,
the tabloids were like,
"Daniel Radcliffe's a porn star now!"
And then like people were
really trying to drag him
because obviously, British tabloids
are like the fucking worst on earth.
Like they're so bad.
- They're like drama
YouTubers, you know, just-
- Just imagine if every newspaper
just turned into Keemstar.
- Yeah, basically.
No, but like it's weird
because remember when someone
like Leonardo DiCaprio was
seen as the teen heartthrob,
you know?
- "The Titanic" guy.
- "The Titanic" guy, you know?
And how hard he had to work
to like change that image
even though, even back then-
- I mean, aging, right?
- No, no, but even back then,
he was like a hell of an actor.
And I don't think people gave
him enough credit at the time.
I mean, I remember it was
like a prevailing joke
where it's just like, if you
ever feel bad about your day,
remember that you have
the same amount of Oscars
as Leonardo DiCaprio.
(laughing)
- He finally got one, he finally got one.
But now you see him aged up and it's like,
he couldn't be more different.
- He didn't age up, he glowed up.
- He fucking glowed up.
- That boy glowed up.
- Yeah. Did you watch...
You know what else here I
actually quite enjoyed recently?
- What?
- "The Suicide Squad",
not "Suicide Squad."
- Oh, "The Suicide Squad."
- "The Suicide Squad."
- Yeah, there's two Suicide Squads?
- There's a newer one
that released on HBO.
- So the one, I know
James Gunn directed it.
- Oh.
- Was that good?
- Really good. Really, really good.
- Really?
- Really fun.
- Better than Snyder cut?
- Oh my God.
It's like night and day.
- Did you watch the Snyder cut?
- Yeah, it was awful.
I wanted to die.
It was terrible.
What is it? My name's Katana.
That means sword or something in Japanese.
That's like the best line.
(laughing)
- Is that a real line?
- Yeah, one of the swords is like,
"Her name's Katana. It
means sword in Japanese."
(laughing)
- Oh Jesus Christ.
- Yeah.
It's something along those lines.
I could be misquoting.
Yeah. It was really good.
Idris Elba was the main character in it
and Idris Elba is just a
pleasure to watch always,
he seems to always just kill it.
And John Cena's really good in it.
- Oh yeah, John Cena.
- He plays like a psychopath justice man.
It's so good.
So yeah, he plays a character
called like Peacemaker, is it?
And he's just like a fucking murderer,
but he's just like, "It's all for peace.
It's all for peace."
And so he's very funny, really good in it.
Really, really, really, it just, it works.
And then he's getting his
own movie now, "Peacekeeper."
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Well, John's Cena's just
like fucking hilarious
in every role I see him in.
- He's really good.
- He's a really good actor.
- He's actually a good actor. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, the whole film
was just really good,
really fun, really well made.
- Is it like a standalone
thing or is it gonna-
- Yep. Standalone. Completely...
As far as I know they're
not doing a sequel.
I don't know though.
- 'Cause nowadays you just
can't have a superhero movie
without someone being
like, "Oh, this is part two
of the cinematic universe.
- I think it's, just go watch it.
I guess the other characters,
like Peacemaker's getting his own thing.
But in terms of like this thing,
dude, you can just watch it.
- Suicide Squad Cinematic
Universe starting now.
- You can just watch it
and turn your brain off
like it's really good-
- Does it have anything
to do with the original?
- No.
- 'Cause I watched the
original and I'm just like,
this is the most five-hour 10
movie I've seen in my life.
- It's in the same thing so
it's like the same premise,
but good.
(Joey laughing)
So like-
- It was a soft reboot.
- Yeah, it's a reboot,
but like just watch it.
It's one of those films
where like you don't have
to pay much attention.
It's just turn your brain off,
a really good time for two hours.
- At which point are we just
gonna not be able to track
which new superhero franchises,
like which one's a reboot,
which one's are building onto
like the Cinematic Universe?
Which one fits into one?
- I already am at that stage.
- I'm burnt out on superheros.
- Is the new "Batman" film,
is that part of the original?
Is that something separate
or is that following on
from like these Zack Snyder "Batman"?
I'm so fucking confused.
- All right, controversial take.
As much as Batman is a superhero,
I don't watch "Batman"
movies as a superhero movie.
It doesn't feel like a
superhero movie to me.
- Yeah.
- I kind of agree with that.
- Well, I feel like
that's ever since the
"Dark Knight" trilogy.
- Yeah.
- Because that kind of like,
I feel like that kind of redefined-
- Yeah, you don't get the,
whereas you watch a Marvel movie,
you know exactly what you're getting.
- Yeah.
- And like, to some extent
you do with "Batman" as well,
but for some reason-
- When "Batman" goes
down that route though,
they do it in like kind of campy
tongue-in-cheek route, right?
Like the George Clooney "Batman" route.
- 'Cause it's just like
with the "Batman" movies
it's like I always think is
this like a "Batman" movie
or a "Batman" in the DC Universe movie,
because if they make Batman in a movie
that has to integrate with
the rest of the DC Universe,
there are some rules that you need
to like acknowledge, you know?
Whereas if it's a
standalone "Batman" movie,
you can do whatever the
fuck you want with that.
- Yeah, he's such a weirdo.
John Wayne's just bizarre.
Like what the fuck is he doing?
(all laughing)
Why is this this man's hobby?
But I mean, yeah, I've really
enjoyed the "Batman" movies.
And again, yeah, like I
said, when it comes around
I don't feel like it's the same thing.
And when I watch a Marvel movie,
they've kind of gone to
this formula recently
that is kind of really
boring and predictable
where it'll be like, "All right,
we're gonna have the thing
with the really big stakes
but we'll crack a few jokes along the way,
of course, we're a family-friendly movie."
And so now they've all turned into
these pseudo action
comedies in some aspects.
Like "Thor: Ragnarok"
really like led the way for this I think.
After "Thor: Ragnarok" like
every single Marvel movie
had to be funny.
- I think it was always like that.
- No.
- It was always like that.
- It really turned up to 10.
- It was like, you watched
the first "Avengers"
and you're just like,
"Oh, everyone's got quips.
Everyone's got something funny to say."
- Yeah, but it's just
like "Thor: Ragnarok"
was more of a comedy movie
than an action movie.
Did you watch it?
- Yeah, of course
I watched it.
- There was more jokes
than fucking plot points in that thing.
- Yeah, but that's also
what I liked about it.
- Yeah, I did too.
- But I'd argue like, so is
like "Guardians of the Galaxy,"
which came before "Thor" right?
I feel like it's the
same kind of vain, but-
- But it just felt like
everything started doing that.
- Yeah, I feel like everything's
just kind of ramped up.
I'm not sure if the newest
model of movies do it or not,
because I haven't watched them obviously.
- Apparently "Eternals" has something-
- [Man] I think "Thor:
Ragnarok is just that formula
because Taika Waititi
was was directing it,
because that's like basically his formula.
- I see, I see.
- [Man] His staff was like tired
of doing all Shakespearian thing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, well, every single
god damn Marvel movie now
has the funny guy there.
Right? Someone who's like
just there to crack jokes.
- You mean Iron Man?
- Well, yeah.
Well, no, he doesn't crack jokes,
I mean, there's someone
else like, "Oh gosh, geez.
I don't know what was going on."
I don't know, some fucking
terrible joke to do.
I don't know.
- [Man] "Ant-Man" in general.
Like most of it. Like all of it.
- Yeah, but who gives
a fuck about Ant-Man?
- I give a fuck about "Ant-Man," okay?
That was a fun movie.
- It's like the D tier
of fucking Marvel characters, all right?
Like literally, no one gave
a shit about "Ant-Man."
- Well, I feel like that's
what they're doing now
with like the newer superhero movies
where like some of them you watch
and you're just like, "Oh,
you're really scraping
the bottom of the barrel."
- That's why I just like don't care
about Marvel movies anymore.
Like literally the last
good Marvel movie I watched
was probably like "Iron Man 2."
- What! (laughing)
- Yeah.
- "Infinity War" was
just, did you watch that?
- No.
- Oh, it's such a good film.
Like "Infinity War"
was actually very good.
- I only know about the film
through all the fucking memes.
- Oh, is that the last
Marvel movie you've watched?
- Probably.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
You don't go to the cinema much, huh?
- No, I just don't watch
fucking Marvel films
because I just don't care
about super hero stuff.
Like, wait.
Wait.
Fucking "Deadpool" was Marvel, right?
- Technically it was Marvel,
but it was also Fox owned.
- But it doesn't feel like a Marvel film.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- Well, yeah,
because it's kind of, it's
in the X-Men universe, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- More along those lines.
- Yeah.
- But the X-Men Universe
has gone to shit too.
- Yeah, the X-Men
Universe has gone to shit.
Which sucks because I really
enjoyed the X-Men stuff.
- Well, "Logan" was like the best film,
the last best X-Men film.
- Well yeah, I agree.
- And then every subsequent film
with anything to do with
X-Men was just terrible.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I don't
even even think X-Men
was like that great of a
franchise to begin with.
- Well, they've always struggled with it.
They've always struggled to-
- Yeah, they've had like some good films
in the X-Men franchise,
but if you take a franchise as a whole
and lay them in front of me, it's like,
I think there's more bad movies
than there are good movies
in the X-Men franchise.
- Yeah, especially the new stuff.
- And any movies out now you
want to go and watch, Garnt?
- I want to watch, what's
out in cinemas right now?
- "Dune."
"Dune." That's the one I want to watch.
That's pretty much the only thing
that I've been hyped about.
I want to watch "Shang-Chi" I guess.
When that's coming out on like Blu-ray?
(Joey laughing)
- I don't know.
It might already be out on DVD.
- It's already out on DVD?
- You still buy Blu-rays?
- No, because like when
it's out on Blu-ray,
that's when it's out to the public.
That's how like my mind
fucking works I guess.
It's rare for me to go to
a cinema to watch a movie
because that means I better be
hyped for this fucking movie.
- Yeah, yeah, you said that
last time we talked about it.
- [Man] End of this month.
- Yeah, what other movies
are coming out this...
- I still wanna go see "Belle."
- Normally the holiday period
has a lot of stuff coming out.
The new "King's Man" movie coming out.
- Oh yeah.
- Don't care. I don't care.
- I kind of want to watch that.
- "King's Man" is definitely
I can watch this at home kind of movie.
- Right.
- I'm not going out of my way
to watch "King's Man."
- I want to see the new "Matrix" movie
whenever that comes out.
- Oh, I'm watching that in cinemas.
I'm watching that in cinemas.
- That's all I really know.
- When is the next "John
Wick" movie coming out?
That's what I want to know.
- Soon, soon.
- It is actually soon?
- [Man] Oh wait. Sorry. I
think there's still filming so.
- It's been like two years.
- Yeah.
- Come on.
I need it!
- It takes time to make a masterpiece.
- I need it!
- Is it Donnie, what's his name?
Donnie Yen. Yeah?
He's in the new "John Wick."
- He is?
- Yeah.
- Donnie Yen?
- Yeah, he took a selfie
with Keanu Reeves.
- What!?
Oh, I love Donnie Yen, he's great.
- So when you go to a screening
and it's like a hype screening,
like the new "Avengers" movie.
- I hate it when it's full.
- Do you think if the crowd is hyped up
and reacts to it and says shit-
- I hate that.
- Okay.
- I think we've established
this before on the podcast actually.
- Yeah.
- Have we?
- We've spoken about this before.
- Yeah.
I hate going to a cinema
where the crowd is loud.
- Yeah. Yeah, me too.
We've definitely said this on an episode.
This is deja vu, the episode.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah.
Yeah, I said like, I'm not
here to see a fucking concert.
I'm here to see a movie.
So it's like, I hate it when
people are like whispering
and being like, "Oh, this is the part
where this thing comes."
I'm like, "Shut up, shut up!"
- Yeah, but like when a hype scene happens
and the fucking cinema erupts.
Do you like it when it happens or-
- Okay, when it's like at the climax,
yeah, it's fine.
But like when they're
nonstop doing it, yeah,
like shut the fuck up.
- Okay. Yeah.
- But like if it's like, okay,
yeah, like the scene in "Endgame"
when he gets the fucking hammer,
all right, sure, everyone lost their shit.
- Nah, I hate it.
I want it to be completely silent.
- I was annoyed in "Endgame though,
because the guy next to kept,
like he'd already seen it.
And so was with someone
and he kept telling them,
"Oh, this part's gonna be sick.
And I'm like, "We're in the movie.
Shut the fuck up! Let him watch it.
You're telling me, I'm
right next to you. Shut up!"
- What'd you think's
the best cinematic
experience you've had then?
- "John Wick 3."
- That shit was amazing.
I loved watching that in cinemas.
The cinema was empty.
I had a great time. It was beautiful.
I watched like the last
viewing of the day.
It was totally empty.
I got to like put my feet up
on the chair in front of me.
Had popcorn, it was beautiful.
It was wonderful.
- I mean, I said it in
the previous episode,
but "Dune" was fucking amazing for me.
Yeah.
- That was the best cinematic
experience you've ever had?
- Of recent time that I can remember, yes.
That was incredible.
- Honestly, any movie with
like a Hans Zimmer soundtrack,
you don't hear the fucking soundtrack,
you fucking feel-
- You feel that shit, yeah.
- Holy shit, man.
- That Dolby digital audio 7.1
shit your pants experience.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- My God, dude.
When I went to go see fucking
"Inception" in cinemas,
the first time you hear that boom,
like I told my colon was gonna explode
from how bassy that shit was.
- This man must like
edit on like fucking iPod
like first-generation headphones
'cause like no way can a man
listen to that much bass daily.
Like they can't be healthy.
- And not be deaf.
- Yeah, yeah.
He must listen to them through
like some shitty earphones
so he can barely hear it.
So he's like, "Oh shit, it
needs more bass I think."
- And this point, he doesn't listen.
He fucking feels the bass.
(both laughing)
- What if he like goes
to the cinema, he's like,
"Fuck, that's how much bass I put in?
Shit. I didn't realize, I
couldn't hear it. Fuck."
- More bass!
- [Connor] Jesus Christ.
- Cut the subwoofers on
his fucking speakers, man.
I can't imagine.
- I'd like to think he's just editing
off of laptop speakers.
(all laughing)
On like Garage Band or something.
(Garnt laughing)
Add more bass I think. (laughing)
It needs a little more bass I think.
- Why Hans Zimmer's house
doesn't have any windows.
(laughing)
It just explodes.
- Imagine being Hans Zimmer's neighbor.
Fuck, bro.
(laughing)
It's 2:00 a.m. and all I hear is bass.
I think there's an alien
spaceship docking outside.
There's so much bass going on.
- Nope, it's just Hans.
- Hans, man, come on, man.
You know it's 3:00 a.m.
Our kids are going to school
tomorrow. Can you please stop?
We understand you're making the soundtrack
to "Inception" but this-
- [Joey] It sounds lit,
Hans, but not right now.
- Come on, man.
This is too much, man.
Come on, please. Hans, stop, stop.
- Can you imagine if
Hans Zimmer was Japanese?
My God, his neighbors must think
that there is like a
magnitude six earthquake
every other day.
(laughing)
- If Hans was Japanese he'd be like,
"I would like to buy the
entire building please."
(laughing)
How much rent is that?
Easy. I got you.
- No, Hans Zimmer has to like
locate his house in a place
where seismographs cannot pick it up
because it'll false positive
earthquakes otherwise.
- He'll like set off an earthquake warning
every other day.
- Hans Zimmer is always recording audio.
(imitates alarm beeping)
- Hans Zimmer is testing
out his new subwoofer.
(all laughing)
- It's terrible. Oh my God.
Oh my lord.
- Worth it, though. It's fucking amazing.
- Man, you know what the hardest thing
about being an adult is that
I realized the other day?
- Go on.
Go on, youngest one here.
- I thought you said my mom or something.
(Joey laughing)
- I was like what do you mean-
- That too. Daddy.
- What is it?
- Something that you can't
be prepared for as a child.
Something that you don't get exposed to.
- Menopause.
- Yes.
Obviously.
Picture it, I was at my local bakery
and I go to go and get my favorite item.
They changed the recipe,
they changed the item.
It's no longer the same.
They substitute the materials
that made this fantastic piece of food.
- What do the kids call
that again? Pain picker.
- Yeah.
You know, no one prepares you
for your favorite food
items at a fast food chain
or a food place changing.
- I agree.
- How do you deal with that?
How do you cope with that?
- I can do one better.
- Okay.
- So you go to a restaurant,
it's a local restaurant.
It's like a local, you
know, local restaurant.
It's not a chain or anything.
It's just it's your
local restaurant. Right?
And then one day you go
there and for some reason
you don't know why, the food
just tastes different, right?
The food just doesn't hit as hard.
And you can't put your finger
on why until you realize,
oh, the chef's gone somewhere else.
That food will never
taste the same ever again.
- The chef's gone independent.
- Because it was the chef all the time
that made the food tastes good.
It wasn't the restaurant itself.
- I have actually had that in Japan once
and it was so fucking trash.
Like I never wanted to cry more
while eating food in my life.
I'm like, "This doesn't taste bad,
but my childhood is just
over there somewhere."
- I agree that's bad,
but I think the fast food one's worse,
'cause the fast food is like comfort.
You know?
You always go to get the
same thing with fast food.
That's what it's selling point is.
- No, I think the local
restaurant is the comfort.
- [Connor] No, no, no.
- It's like a person who
murdered your best friend
is just wearing their skin
and then he walks into your house
and he's just pretending
to be your best friend.
And it's just like-
- Hello friend, it's me.
- So McDonald's did this like in Japan,
here's a problem with Japan.
And you've got these
amazing seasonal items,
or items that come around is it,
they only last like three weeks.
So when you find an absolute
banger of a food item
on a menu, you know the time is ticking.
but you're okay with it leaving
'cause you you knew the rules of the game
when you went into order that.
You knew that you were about to get hurt,
but you didn't care.
You wanted that spicy.
- You knew the rules.
- And so did I.
- You knew the rules and so did I.
- I hate that how said that
'cause I was thinking it.
(Garnt laughing)
- You knew the rules and so did I.
- I'm like don't say it, this is dumb.
- But when there's an item
that has been there for like ages,
we're talking like years-
- [Garnt] Did you get
Rickrolled by the slice?
- Yes, and then, fuck you.
And then, and then the food item changes.
You have been doing this your whole life.
You've been eating there, you've
been getting this one item
and it changes.
It feels like a betrayal of the century.
Like you could have murdered my family.
- You walk in, you look at
the menu, and you just fear.
(Garnt and Joey hum
"Never Gonna Give You Up")
- I'll have the...
What do you mean? Where's it gone?
Why would they do this?
This must be a mistake.
I'll have this item.
They said they don't have it.
I cry. No. This must be a mistake.
Please check the back, check the back.
There must be some left!
Please!
- No, I do still think the
local restaurant is worse.
- The local restaurant one hits the worst.
- [Connor] Because you
move, you move all the time.
- Have you experienced it though?
- Yeah, I have, but you fucking move.
- No, no, no.
- What do you mean you move?
- Look, if it's a local restaurant,
you move every fucking two years, Garnt.
- Well, no, no.
I mean, like the local restaurant,
which is like the same people
running the restaurant,
it's just the chef's different.
- Yeah, but like fast food items,
that's some stuff that's
been there for like decades
that they change.
Your local restaurant,
you'll only experience it
for like two years at a time
'cause that's why you live there.
- No. No
- Yeah. Yeah.
- There are some restaurants
that are just like,
you never find food as good as that again.
- Where?
- Anywhere.
- There are some places like anywhere,
anywhere you live.
- [Connor] Yeah, but you move
every move every two years
or every year.
- Yeah, but sometimes you go
back to the restaurant and,
oh, that's the worst though.
when you go back to your hometown
and there is like this specific restaurant
and it's just changed, right?
And you'll never get a taste
of your childhood ever again.
Or you'll never get a taste
of that taste of home ever again.
And you didn't know before you move
that you were saying
goodbye to that piece.
- That Indonesian restaurant
in my local mall in Australia.
The moment that disappeared,
I had to like hug my mom.
It was like losing a family member.
- I still think when they
change an item of groceries
or fast food is worse,
'cause that's what you have
all the time, you know?
Like I remember I used
to get Dairylea Dunkers
all the time in the UK.
- Yeah.
- Even as an adult.
It's like, I don't know how to explain it.
It's called-
- Great.
- It's kind of like a
fake cheese cream whip.
- That sounds disgusting.
- No, no, no.
It's not like a whip though.
It's like a cheese kind of spread.
How would you describe Dairylea Dunkers?
- Ah...
- How would you describe it?
It's kind of like a breadstick.
- It's like a breadstick that you dunk in-
- It's like a breadstick in one part
and then like a cheese kind of esque thing
in the other.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah.
- You probably have something-
- Yeah, yeah.
We have something like that.
- So they made that in the UK, right?
But then I think they changed their recipe
when I was like 20 years old.
They changed how they made the cheese
and it's tasted significantly cheaper.
- Why are we eating
that at 20 years of age?
- Bro, don't question why the fuck
I was eating that at 20 years,
'cause it was really good.
Like it was a really nice snack.
It tasted amazing and I'd love to get it.
And it was a blast of
nostalgia every time.
And they had it in my local supermarket
and I would get it.
And one time I got it, I
bought like a four pack,
a big like, like a family
four pack, I stocked up.
I was like, "Hell yeah."
I dug in, right?
I opened it up, one bite and I'm like,
"Something has changed.
There has been a
disturbance on the cheese.
- Isn't that the worst though,
and then at that moment, right?
It's when you realize I bought
a whole pack of this shit.
- I did another one and I was like,
"They've changed it, they've
definitely changed it."
- It's definitely not me.
- I asked my friend,
I was like, "Listen, did
you have the old one?
They were like, "Yeah."
And then I gave it to
them and they were like...
Like, "Okay, try it now,
like try this new one.
Tell me if it's changed."
They're like, "No, it
doesn't taste any different."
I'm like, "When's the
last time you had it?
They were like, "Over a year ago."
I'm like, "You wouldn't know, then.
You wouldn't know."
- [Joey] 'Cause it's
a slow gradual change.
- It's one year, you wouldn't know.
So I emailed the company.
- Did you actually?
- Yeah.
'Cause I wanted to know if they did it.
I wanted to know if I
was being crazy, right?
- Yeah, you're definitely
crazy. That's for sure.
- Who did you email?
- So the.. (laughing)
- The email on the back of the packet?
- Yeah, yeah.
So I found the company online. Right?
And this is only because
I wouldn't have done this
if my friend didn't say,
"No, they didn't change it."
I was like, "They changed it."
And they were like,
"They didn't change it."
I'm like, "They changed it."
And so I found out the company-
- It sounds like a deleted
scene from "American Psycho."
It's like you're so infatuated.
- [Connor] Yeah, I understand
this sounds stupid.
- Yeah, it's because it is.
- Sounds like an "Always Sunny" episode.
- But I wanted-
- He didn't realize the cheese was wrong.
- They deny it, Connor
goes to the fucking factory
and be like," Tell me the truth!
I know you're lying to me!"
- I wanted to know
because I wanted to know
if my taste buds have changed
or if I was being crazy
or I just needed to know.
It was driving me insane.
So I emailed them, right? No response.
And I was like, "What the fuck?"
So I call up their customer
service, 'cause I'm like,
now I need to know
'cause they didn't reply.
Right?
So I call them up and I asked
them and I'm like, "Hey,
so this type of Dairylea Dunker thing,
did you change the recipe at
any point in recent time?"
And they were like, "Hmm,
can I get back to you?"
And I was like, "You're not
gonna get fucking back to me."
- Yeah.
- How long ago was this?
- Oh, this was like three years ago.
- [Garnt] Oh okay.
- [Joey] And I'm still
waiting for the reply.
- It was like four years
ago. Four years ago.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- So yeah, I gave them my number
and they actually called me back.
- Wow.
- They said no.
And I was like, "What?
No, no, no."
- Wow.
Who would've fucking thought?
- I said, "Check again,
check again." Right?
So then I was like, "What the fuck, man?"
I was so annoyed, man.
I thought, fuck, like, oh my God.
I fucked it up, man.
Why am I an idiot? Why
did I think it changed?
- Yeah.
- A year later,
I got an email reply
saying that they had
changed one of the aspects
of like the cheese or
something that they did.
And I was like, I felt vindicated, bro.
I felt like, you know how like
when you watch those movies
about someone being
wrongly convicted in court
and then they finally get out?
I felt like that.
I was like, "Thank you. Thank
you guys. I'm finally free.
I finally solve the mystery
that they fucking changed it."
- I can't believe they
emailed you back a year later.
- Yeah. Me too, me too.
- Yeah.
- My God, like that employee
must've really fucking cared,.
you know?
- I don't know why.
- We care about all our customers.
- I'm not really sure
how that happened though.
It was really bizarre.
- Somebody like fucking
dusted off their inbox
and be like, (blows)
remember that one guy,
he emailed us last year
if the ingredients changed?
- They're probably sorting
out the spam folder
and they're like, "Oh, what's this?"
- I didn't expect them to
even answer my call back,
but the fact they call me
back just to tell me no,
I was like that's weird.
- It's probably because
you're probably the one person
who actually fucking called them.
- [Connor] Yeah, great
customer service you guys have.
At least I can say that much.
- I've never heard of a single person
actually phoning customer
service for like a food item.
- And you call me a Karen.
- No, it wasn't a Karen.
I wasn't like, "I demand to know!"
I was like, "By the way,
did you change the recipe by any chance?"
- It doesn't matter how
strongly you say it.
- What do you mean, a Karen-
- It's the fact that
you even fucking did it
is like more telling than anything.
- Why am I not allowed to ask that?
- Because who cares?
- I care.
- [Joey] Who actually fucking cares?
- Why am I not allowed to know?
- It's a cheese stick
that is given to children.
It is the literal children's snack.
- And I wanted to know.
- You're an adult.
- I wanted to know.
I didn't ask rudely.
I just asked them, "By the way,
just wondering, did
you change the recipe?"
Is that rude? That's not rude.
- I don't know, man.
- It's not about being
rude, it's just like-
- [Connor] It's strange.
I understand it's strange.
- Yeah, it's very strange.
- [Connor] But there's
nothing wrong with it.
- The determination.
- What what's wrong with that?
It took like 10 seconds to email them.
- But the fact that you
also called them up.
- Wait, wait, I got to know,
how long did they put you on hold?
- No, like instant.
- How long was that ringing?
- It was instant.
They literally-
- Yeah, because no one
probably calls that number.
- Yeah, because no one's calling them.
Who's calling them?
- I can only imagine like the receptionist
to be like, "That phone rings?"
- Disappointed.
- Well, they had to blow the dust off it
before they pick it up.
Well, 'cause I think
what inspired me to do it
is that on UK there's a
TV show on channel four
where they would try and find out where
food items came from in the UK.
So like if it was like canned tomatoes
and it would say like "made
in Argentina" or something,
they would just like go
on this relentless triad
to go and like fucking find out
where it actually came from.
And then they would go
and visit the place where it came from.
- [Joey] Right. I mean,
that's interesting.
- Yeah, I think I was inspired.
I was like, I want to
know, tell me, tell me.
You know, I understand that it's not,
I've never done that since, but-
- Yeah.
- I don't think
I was being rude or anything.
I just asked them if they changed it.
- No, I'm not criticizing you being rude.
- I feel like I've done
something badly here.
I'm being criticized for this.
Fuck you guys.
I wanted know one of
my favorite child food-
- No, you're not being criticized
for being rude or anything.
I'm just like shocked
that you were that bored.
- No, it wasn't boredom,
it was determination.
There's a difference.
- I'm just surprised you with that bored
to be that determined.
- No, I mean, I had other stuff to do.
I just ignored it.
- Clear, they weren't that important then.
- Are you telling me
that you've never procrastinated
in intriguing ways on your work?
- Yes, but-
- I wish I could say I could procrastinate
in intriguing ways.
No, it's never an intriguing way.
- No, if that is what is the benchmark
for intriguing then no-
- I just load up a meme on
YouTube and I'm just like fuck.
- I just like, I don't know, play a game.
(laughing)
You know?
- You know, in some weird way in my head
to justify my procrastination,
I feel like if I've done
something that was on my mind
that I wanted to do,
it's almost not procrastination in a way.
- [Joey] All right.
- Like when I'm (indistinct)
sometimes there are some videos
that I don't want to film
because I'm dreading the filming process,
'cause it's quite a difficult video.
I might struggle with it or I'm not too,
I guess I'm not like a
100% on the video idea,
but I don't know until it's edited, right?
- Yeah.
- So I kind of dread it.
So sometimes I might just put it off.
Sometimes it's like great procrastination
like doing my chores.
I'm like this is procrastination
that is justified in my head.
But I know-
- But is it really?
- No, it is because I should
have done that one thing,
but I'm just,
I'm lying to myself by doing
tasks that I need to do
that could easily be done any other time,
but I'm just pushing forward now
because I don't want to do that one thing.
That is procrastination.
- That is because that's
the procrastination I do.
- [Connor] It's efficient procrastination,
but it's still procrastination.
- I don't think there's such a thing
as efficient procrastination.
- No, there is, there is.
- Okay, there's slightly more
efficient procrastination,
but at the same time, you have
a task that you need to do
and you are putting that task off, right?
You can lie to yourself and say,
"Hey, I'm doing something else
productive, like cleaning,"
which I do as well.
But like, I'm just like-
- No.
Sometimes there are videos
that you need to do ASAP.
Right?
And you're just putting them off
because you don't want to do it.
- Yeah.
- Right?
That's procrastination,
regardless of what you're
doing to put it off,
you know, you could be
doing CPR on someone
and saving their life.
You're still procrastinating
on that video, bro.
Let them die, bro. Do the video.
I'm kidding. It's a joke.
I would not have chosen to clean that day.
The only reason I chose to clean
was because I didn't want
to do the fucking video.
Thus I'm procrastinating on that video.
- Do you ever do the cleaning
where you don't need to procrastinate?
- No.
(Garnt laughing)
- So basically you
procrastinate on the cleaning
until you tried to procrastinate
with something else
and then you procrastinate by cleaning.
- Have you not found
yourself doing those tasks
that you've been putting off
when you really don't
want to do something?
- Oh yeah, I just don't lie to myself.
- Yeah, it's horrible.
- I just don't lie to myself
because I only clean
when I'm procrastinating on making videos.
Right?
And then the other day-
- So you admit it.
- The other day,
I just like cleaned my house
about five million times.
And I'd run out of things
to procrastinate on
so I made this video called like,
"Jojo fans when they figure out
their bros don't suck dick."
And that was made because
I was procrastinating
on making videos and I'd
already cleaned the house
so like... (laughing)
- That is really scraping
the bottom of the barrel.
- So that is still procrastinating.
- Yeah, I know still procrastinating.
That's what I'm saying.
- You just said it wasn't.
You said it wasn't procrastinating.
- No, I'm saying like
there's no such thing,
like every procrastination is made equal.
- Is it procrastination
if it's monetizable?
- Yes.
It's still procrastination. Okay.
- I was trying to help you, man.
(laughing)
I threw the rope and
you threw it back at me.
What the fuck?
- No, I'm arguing-
- [Connor] What do you do
when you don't want to film a video.
Oh, sorry, you were arguing. Go on.
- I'm arguing that all
procrastination is made the same.
It's essentially you
are putting something,
an important task-
- But that's what I argued
and you disagreed with me.
- You said that you can like
min-max procrastination, right?
- Wait, no, no, no.
I said you're still procrastinating
even if you're like cleaning.
That's still procrastinating.
That's what I argued.
- Oh, I thought you-
- I never said it was a good thing.
- Oh, I thought you were
just arguing the opposite.
- No!
- Okay.
- I didn't say that at all!
I said...
Listen to me, Garnt!
This is why the Trash
Taste Podcast is arguments
because Garnt-
- [Joey] Because no one fucking listens.
- I understand.
Fuck you, Connor, you're wrong.
- You know, I just want it
to disagree with, Connor.
- Mother fucker, Garnt!
I literally said your point.
I was like, hold on for a second.
I had to readjust for a second.
- Yeah, I was like halfway
through that conversation
I'm like you just made the same point.
- Yeah, you just said my
point. What the fuck...
- Sorry, I was just back
to the fucking Dairylea.
My mind was just like
I can't believe this-
- Do you like the Babybels?
Do you have those in Australia?
Yeah.
- Fucking love Babybels.
I miss those man.
- Nothing beats cheese string.
We've talked about this.
Nothing beats cheese string.
- Cheese string.
- Cheese string's
on another level, but
Babybels next in line.
- Does America have Babybel?
- All this talk of food is
making me fucking starving.
- I'm starving too.
(Garnt laughing)
Let's get some food.
- Yeah. Fuck the episode, let's get food.
- That salad wasn't enough
for me earlier today.
- All right, yeah.
- I'm actually starving right now.
All this talk about food, man.
- Yeah, fuck the episode.
Here's the Patrons.
All right. Yeah, whatever.
- Gamers, we're about to have
some fucking Dairylea Dunkers right now.
- Old recipe Dairylea Dunkers.
- Apparently not because it's shit.
Even though it's the same recipe.
- No, no, no. We don't know that.
They were two different companies
so one of them said no
one of them said yes so.
- So we will never know.
- What was your favorite
snacks growing up?
Have they changed over time?
I'm sure you've had a local restaurant-
- Have you ever called
them up or emailed them?
- I'm sure you've had a local restaurant
change on you as well.
That is probably heartbreaking.
- Yep.
- I'm pretty sure.
I mean, I feel like being
told Santa isn't real
every time I go to my local restaurant
and something's changed about it.
You know?
- Get over it, Garnt.
It's called being an adult, Garnt.
Get over it.
- Joey, do the Patreon thing.
- Okay, if you'd like to support the show
then make sure to go to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us your memes on the subreddit
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
And yeah, don't email companies
about fucking children's snacks.
- I think that's okay. You can do that.
If you're nice, be polite.
- Well, don't do it,
if you have shit to do.
- You know, people email us
and if they're polite, I don't care.
You know? It's whatever, you know?
- You know what I wonder,
like how did they find
out that, for example,
like the horse meat thing in the UK?
Who figured that out?
- Someone who eats a lot of horse meat.
- Yeah, someone who just loves horses.
I smell it.
- Someone probably just tested it.
- Why?
- People like this.
- No, scientists always test
stuff from supermarkets.
- Do they?
- Yeah, you can't just not test the meat.
What do you mean?
How else we gonna check
it's what they say it is?
- Well, clearly no one did for a while
because the horse meat was in there.
- Well, I mean, you know,
it's constantly checked.
I mean, you could do it one
way, change your supplier
and then no one checks.
- Yeah. Fair enough.
- Oh, we're getting something different.
- Anyway, horse meat. We're hungry.
- We're fucking hungry.
I'm fucking hungry.
- See you guys next episode, bye!
- Bye!
(upbeat music)